Yes.
And we're live.
Hello,
Danica Patrick.
Hi.
Welcome to the show.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
I appreciate it.
I'm excited to be here.
You're an intense lady.
You've got a lot of intensity when I met
you like right away I'm like,
whoa.
Got to take this one in.
Well,
you know,
it's the handshake and then it's the uh,
you know when someone actually looks you
in the eye.
Well you have to be intense.
I mean what you do for living is
probably one of the craziest things a
human being can do.
Do you think so it's up there for a job.
How fast you go?
Uh,
200.
Yeah,
I mean like,
you know,
Nascar's top speed is probably two 15
indy cars and maybe more like two 40.
And I'm going to do the Daytona 500 next
month and then the indy 500 in May.
So,
um,
those are going to be my last two races.
So,
um,
the last one's ever,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah,
it's a,
this is my Danica double goodbye tour.
Why are you doing that?
How come you doing a Danica Double
Goodbye Cook?
Is it enough is enough.
I'm ready.
Um,
I mean I love racing,
but I love other things too.
So,
um,
you know,
I'm okay with transitioning out and
there was a lot of things that were kind
of just pointing me in this direction.
Yeah.
In 2017 stuff that has never happened to
me before.
Um,
to kind of,
yeah.
Head towards the exit a little bit,
but I'm good with that.
I'm a very decisive person,
so,
um,
this is probably one of them that I
thought about a little bit,
um,
as far as like how to be done or,
or if to be done I guess.
But,
um,
the how was the hardest part?
My agent kept calling and saying,
what about this and what if you did
that?
And I'm like,
no,
no.
You all need to get ready for me to be
done,
please.
Wow.
And,
uh,
so then he came up with the,
it's like,
what if you finish up at the,
at Daytona for the 500?
And I was like,
what about the indy 500?
And he goes,
and I was really only referring to the
indy 500.
And he was like,
well I'd,
I'd love you to do both.
And I was like,
oh well that's a good idea.
So,
um,
there's this thing in racing called the
double,
which is doing the indy 500,
um,
on Memorial Day weekend on Sunday and
then flying straight to charlotte to do
the coke 600 afterwards.
And that's kind of known as the double.
Um,
but this is what we're calling the
Danica double and it has to do with just
having spent,
you know,
a chunk of my career in Indycar and a
chunk of my career in Nascar and it just
kinda feels like the right way to go
out.
I don't know.
It didn't,
it did,
it wasn't clear.
It was a bit of a murky end as far as
like,
what's going to happen?
Am I going to race next year full time
or not?
And it just kind of went suit too long
for me to have like a proper,
I'm done sort of moment in my head.
So this was just a great way to do it.
So when you say that things happen in
2017 that didn't happen before?
Like what do you mean?
I got a sponsor leave me.
Uh,
my primary sponsor left at the beginning
of the year.
I may not,
I signed a contract it when mercury was
in retrograde,
so,
you know,
I screwed myself there.
But that stuff don't know.
I don't know.
It was true.
So,
um,
I guess maybe the universe is a little
bit straight
forward than we think it is.
A lot of good things probably happened
during that time just in 2017 or during
Richard,
Shereen Mercury in retrograde.
I don't,
I don't believe in any of that shit.
Oh yeah.
I think people look for some sort of
like hidden meaning to things when it
comes to like astrology.
Yeah.
I do try and understand it.
It's quite,
I'm trying to understand how it really
matters,
but I don't know.
There's definitely some things,
at least with the moon that goes on.
I mean the water changes with the moon,
so doesn't that mean that other thing
should too,
whether it be energetically or something
like that?
I think the the water and the moon thing
kind of makes sense a little bit.
A little bit,
but I think it's probably just like
barely one way or the other.
Just still,
maybe it's a whisper on the wind kind of
stuff.
I think it's more in your head.
So stop putting my crystals outside of
charge under the full moon.
Maybe not so important.
I would say it's not that important.
There was some something someone sent me
about the army using crystals and I was
like,
this has gotta be like an onion article
that the rn,
the army was using crystals for like
medic seat thing.
If you could see it,
find that.
Define it.
Yeah.
This store for wounded people.
Look at this stupid shit.
I don't even,
I don't,
I'm not sure if it's real.
US Army's new holistic medics treating
gunshot wounds with crystals and
essential oils is satire.
Thank you.
I knew essential oils.
Don't you think there's a plant that
cures everything out there?
There probably is something like that in
the Amazon.
Maybe not cures everything,
but this is probably a lot of stuff that
we oils come from,
right?
Yeah.
So pair that up with some high
vibrational stones,
high vibrational stones.
Ooh,
no,
no tents.
So,
um,
back to back to my sponsor leaving me.
You sponsor leaving you,
you will like,
that's it.
Yeah.
It's just a,
never happened to me before.
I've always been someone that's been
really well funded and I always had a
sponsor,
always had a sponsor and never a
problem.
And so,
um,
yeah,
it was just things like that were
happening.
I got an a few big wrecks in a row,
like probably three and six weeks that
were,
Ooh,
you know,
like I was bawling in the medical center
after the third one going,
whoa.
I mean,
I was running like top 10,
and a car blew a rotor and clipped me
and put me in the wall.
I was on fire up.
Another driver broke his back.
I mean,
it was a huge accident.
And I'm like,
what is,
what is the message?
What is someone trying to tell me right
now?
And so,
you know,
after I collected my shit and got my
face looking like halfway decent to go
talk to the media out there,
I finally got out.
But yeah,
just stuff like that was happening and I
was,
I was in a very go with the flow mood in
2017 I wasn't pushing for anything cause
I wasn't really sure what I wanted so I
just let the universe take care of it.
You've got a very interesting way of
looking at things.
You when things go wrong,
you're like,
what is the universe trying to tell me?
You're not like,
well I drive really fucking fast for a
living.
Sometimes shit goes wrong.
That's happens to I,
it seems like
car racing is just inherently crazy.
I mean it's what I was saying when I was
saying you do one of the craziest things
you can for a living going 240 miles an
hour is no joke.
Yeah.
And metal and rubber and things just,
yeah,
trust in something when you're out there
because you're doing,
like you said,
200 plus miles an hour with,
you know,
people that aren't your friends around
you with walls around you as well.
So you know,
you kind of got to put your trust in
something else.
Yeah.
That's why I was getting at that because
I think the way you think is the,
a lot,
it's very similar to the way fighter
pilots think.
Fighter pilots have a lot of weird
superstitions and a lot of,
uh,
a lot of pilots do,
a lot of people that are involved in
intense things.
It's almost like in order to get through
the,
the task at hand,
you almost have to delegate certain
aspects of reality to fate or to chance
or to,
yeah,
I believe that.
Yeah.
I mean they,
uh,
have a tattoo on my back,
one of his in America,
it's an American flag.
I got that when I was 19.
It's like an American flag that fades to
a checkered flag.
And then there's a,
and then I got that when I was 19.
Then when I was about 27,
I went and got the rest,
which was,
um,
Angel Wings and some stars.
And you know,
it's not the most beautiful piece of
art,
but it means something to me.
It won't be really beautiful in 30
years,
I'm sure 40 um,
but it's,
uh,
but yeah,
I am,
my point is,
is that I would definitely pray that,
you know,
I was taken care of and you've got to
hand that off and just go do your damn
job and not be afraid and just trust in
the fate of everything.
And Yeah.
So that's kind of where the angel links,
well,
I think that people that do inherently
risky things oftentimes look for signs
or look for some sort of,
you know,
some direction,
some,
some message from the university.
And that's why I was,
well,
I mean,
I feel like as a race car driver,
I've thought about this a lot lately and
I wonder how much of our job is a little
less even just feeling what's happening
and how much is actually maybe more
intuitive.
Like,
maybe we're,
maybe we're having more intuitive
understanding of what's going on and
what's coming.
Then we realize we just are so,
um,
everything's happening so fast and that
you,
you just think,
oh,
I'm,
I have really good feel.
You know,
I mean,
I'm sure there's some of that too.
But um,
so I think that maybe maybe you're maybe
maybe athletes or people at an elite
level are more in touch with that
intuitive side that um,
finite like last thread of feel.
Maybe it's beyond feel.
It's a knowing
that makes sense.
I mean,
if you think about the amount of time
that you've spent involved in that
intense activity in this,
you know,
they say that people get road rage for
one of the reasons why people get road
rage is because when you're driving you
are reacting to things that could happen
instantaneously very quickly.
So your at a very heightened state and
people,
you know,
someone cuts you off,
you,
they start freaking out.
Like instantly they go from one to 10
right away.
And the reason is because they're always
at seven and they don't even realize
they're at seven.
When you were in the car,
you're probably at like 13.
This one goes to 11.
Yeah.
You,
I mean you're cranked up.
Right.
And so you're probably seeing things and
feeling things at the average person.
Yeah.
They don't experience in their life.
You're just working at that top little
top level of
feeling of,
of um,
focus.
Okay.
Was that,
is that where you call it in the zone?
Yeah.
Where it kind of almost becomes slightly
out of body.
You don't know how it's happening.
It's just happening.
Why would imagine like you kind of melt
away and you're just coming.
Yeah.
We involved,
when I think about what I have to do,
like let's say as an example coming in
for a pit stop and you got your throttle
brake,
clutch gears,
all the different things that you have
to do,
um,
to think about it logically,
what you have to do is so much more
confusing than just going on instinct of
like just do it.
Um,
cause you have to,
you know,
use,
you only have two feet but you have
three pedals and you have to use all
three pedals at some point in time.
But you want to be ready for everything
and you,
you're coming in like what the clutch in
on the break.
But then you have to get back to the,
get to the,
get to the throttle just in time.
But you have to have the clutch in and
you have to hold the brakes so you make
sure you don't roll.
There's all kinds of things you have to
do using all three pedals,
which you have two feet.
And so when you kind of,
when you have to think about what you
have to do,
it's a little more overwhelming than
just doing it.
Do you drive a manual in real life?
I would.
I love it.
Easy.
Yeah,
I do too.
Yeah.
But I mean a lot of people,
it seems like it's kind of a dying
thing.
Yeah,
it is.
I mean even indy cars went to paddle
shifting before I was done,
it was h pattern and then it was
sequential gearbox.
And then it was paddle shifting and
then,
but Nascar,
Nascar is still still got the old h
pattern.
That left leg is important for the whole
feel of the thing.
Right?
Well,
especially in an indy car,
in any car,
you actually have a full on dead pedal.
So you have all three pedals and then
you have a dead pedal,
which is,
is important because you spend a lot of
time with your foot there.
But it is part of the feel.
It is absolutely part of the feel of the
car,
especially with all the g loads.
How did you get involved in racing?
I raced go karts when I was a kid.
Um,
my sister and my sister wanted to race
go carts and I just didn't want to get
left out.
So it turned out I was all right.
It and I kept going.
But it's,
it's a very unusual path.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I did everything though.
I was a,
I played like coach pitch,
then tee ball.
I was in the band,
the choir,
I took voice lessons.
I was,
I played basketball,
volleyball,
cheerleading,
um,
I played in every sport.
Um,
I took tumbling classes and then I also
tried racing.
So you've always been intense?
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Did you know at a certain age that you
wanted to be a race car driver?
Well,
when I was 10,
I decided that I wanted to go to college
for engineering so I could learn how to
work on my race car.
And I realize I did not have to do that.
I did not.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's what I thought.
Wow.
I didn't have to do that.
Be An engineer so that you could work on
your race card.
Do you know,
do you understand how crazy that is?
When I was going to be 10 years old to
three thinking that,
well,
I dunno.
Do you think you're born that way or am
I an old?
Like what do you think about that?
Like to be thinking that way when I'm 10
years old,
like you,
you know,
some people are just so much different
or more mature further along.
Is it,
um,
why do you think that is?
It's a very good question.
I don't,
I think it's entirely possible that
memory gets transferred through DNA and
that there are certain people that have
a long line of adventurous people and
their family and that gets transferred
to the DNA of the children.
I think it's entirely possible.
I have,
I have three children,
not a spiritual reincarnation.
No,
maybe.
I mean,
look,
it's,
that's it.
That's entirely possible too.
I would never,
I would never say no to that because if
you're living this life,
I mean,
nobody asked to live this life.
You just here,
right?
Who knows if you get to do it again,
I mean we're,
we're assuming that you don't get to do
it again because we're assuming that
time goes on this sort of linear way,
but maybe it just does for you in this
life,
it's entirely possible that there's
infinite number of lives being lived out
in,
in infinite timelines,
all simultaneously.
We're just experiencing this one and we
don't even know what happens when we
sleep.
You go to sleep,
close your eyes.
If for some crazy dream about Godzilla
chasing you,
you're on a skateboard.
You wake up in the morning and you just
assume that you're on the same timeline
that you were on before,
you know,
because you have done the astro,
who knows?
I don't,
you know,
I have children.
And then one of the things that's really
fascinating about watching a child
develop from a baby to,
you know,
a kid and see their personalities.
Like you realize like there's a lot of
stuff that's just,
that's what they come with.
Yeah.
They're just,
that's what I'm saying.
So it's,
they're just different.
Why,
you know,
why,
why was I thinking about being an
engineer when I was 10 years old?
Why was I brave enough to go live in
England by myself when I was 16 and all
good with it?
And you know,
why,
why am I in tent?
Why did,
why was I intense when you met me?
You know what I mean?
Well,
I think part of your intensity is
probably,
if I had to guess,
if I could be presumptuous,
your a woman involved in a very manly
activity and I'm sure men probably test
you in some sort of a weird way.
And so I bet along the way you've
developed this sort of like way of
addressing them right away,
like a listen motherfucker
sometimes.
Yeah.
I mean I think you probably have to,
you know,
I would imagine,
yeah,
to be strong you have to,
I remember when I was younger and going
to meetings with companies or team
bosses,
people like that and was the advice
given was don't say,
oh I this and may be like,
you'd be sure about what you want.
And I remember that.
So,
yeah,
in nature versus nurture,
some of it's learned,
but some of it's just there.
Yeah.
You can't turn a timid person to you.
Maybe you could,
but I mean,
it's not,
not likely you would,
you seem to be like this person.
This is just who you are.
If you're telling me that at 10 years
old you were thinking about being an
engineer so you could work on race cars.
That's not normal.
Well,
what's normal though?
What'd you want to do when you were 10
years old?
I had no idea.
I probably wanted to be an artist.
I think I wanted to be an artist.
I mean that,
that follows this vein sort of.
Yeah.
But like I used to want to draw comic
books.
I did a lot of that.
Yeah.
So that was probably what I wanted,
but I was never like,
well I need to do is like I need to
figure out a way to make my hand
stronger so that I draw faster.
And I like
Steven Mind,
I did not go to college.
In fact,
I didn't even finish high school.
You didn't at all?
Nope.
I left when I was 16 and I got my ged.
Wow.
And I failed the first time.
You want to know why?
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
Um,
cause that's like a horrible,
like I failed my ged.
Oh Geez.
Um,
I uh,
the constitution test is something,
at least in Illinois,
I don't know if you have to pass it in
every state,
but in Illinois you do.
And so in eighth grade to go to high
school you have to get a 70% or above to
go to high school.
I got a 70,
so I went to high school.
Now I'm like a 3.5 and above student.
Like I was a's and b's not a problem for
some reason.
The constitution and government and all
of those sectors and names and holy
moly,
it's so confusing to me.
So,
um,
so then when it came time to,
to do my,
take my ged,
I didn't study at all.
I just took the test and I failed the
constitution test.
So I prepare for it.
That's all.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I've never studied in my life so I just
no.
Okay.
Really?
Yeah.
[inaudible] the only thing I study up,
well study,
uh,
if I'm doing a speech,
or if I'm doing something for a,
for a company,
for a sponsor,
and I need to make sure that I have my
talking points ready.
I mean,
I spent 15 minutes or 30 minutes or five
minutes making sure that I'm organized
in my head about what it is that I need
to get out there so that I can do my
job,
um,
and deliver.
But other than that,
I never studied in school.
Keep in mind,
I didn't have to go to school that long.
I never even,
I mean I only went to school until I was
16,
so it's been a really,
really,
really long time since I went to school.
But you're very smart.
Oh,
I don't know.
See,
I,
I know you're smart.
Thank you.
Well,
what do you do you read?
Um,
I actually,
I want to start reading more.
I've got a lot of books that I want to
read.
I started reading a book called the
Holographic universe.
Okay.
Michael Talbot,
right?
Yeah.
It's a good book.
Is that it's weird.
Yeah.
There's a lot of stuff in there.
You're like,
wait a minute.
This kind of drugs like,
cause usually there's a lot of woo in
there.
I think
I'm a little woo.
So it's good.
I,
I'm in simple books like the alchemists
and stuff.
I just really want to read these books.
I mean,
and um,
yeah.
Uh,
she does more woo woo woo woo shit.
Yeah,
I am.
Why do you think that that is the race
car thing?
Do you think that's like the has nothing
to do with it's just who you are.
That's just who I am.
I remember getting a psychic reading
when I was 18 years old living in
England.
Yeah.
I bought like Linda Goodman's love
science like astrology book when I was a
kid.
So when you were 16 and you got a
psychic reading man,
I totally had a mood ring.
Oh,
mood rings are great.
Sorry,
go ahead.
Do what did what did they tell you?
They tell you anything you don't
remember.
I can't remember.
But when I was talking about signing my
contract and um,
or when mercury was in retrograde,
that was,
I,
I talked to an astrologer and she said,
just don't sign any contracts.
And I was like,
well what a bizarre,
I mean I was kind of learning about some
of this stuff cause it was quite a few
years ago now,
but I,
um,
I remember the next day,
it was a year and a half later,
so,
and you know,
the shit hit the fan and I was like,
that damn astrologer was right now.
Okay.
Mercury retrogrades pretty standard
information if you're into strategy at
all.
But,
um,
but yeah,
she said,
uh,
I saw a psychic in Sedona a few years
ago and she said that professionally
over the next four years,
your life's gonna go boom,
boom,
boom.
And I thought,
man,
I'm going to win a bunch of races,
is going to be awesome.
And instead I,
um,
uh,
have clothing line now.
Um,
I have a book that just came out at the
beginning of the year.
Uh,
my wines finally been for sale for a
year now.
Um,
and there's other projects I'm working
on too,
but uh,
and you know,
finishing off my career in a pretty big
way.
So I guess she was right.
I think that lady's full of Shit.
You think so?
I think she looked at you and like,
this chick's gonna kick ass.
Do you think she recognized me?
Then she's like,
okay.
So when I sat down,
she was like,
all right,
the way it works here is like,
I just see words or symbols or things
around you.
So if I just look around like don't
think I'm not paying attention to him,
that's just how I see things.
And so I'm like,
all right,
all right.
So I'm sitting there and she's telling
me all this stuff and she says whatever
my job is,
I travel a lot and things like that.
And then she all of a sudden kind of was
looking at me.
She looked over,
she goes,
celebrities are you a celebrity?
And I was like,
I only am if you think I am.
Just usually how I answer people.
Um,
so I don't know.
Did she know who I was up in Sedona?
They don't watch a lot of TV.
I don't think.
You don't think so?
No.
They snake
and when no one's looking at their lunch
break areas,
just you know,
the rest of crystals on the TV.
I just think he's sending positive
vibes.
Almost all bullshit.
I think almost call psychic stuff is
bullshit.
I think you don't believe in the being
intuitive intuition is a different
thing.
I think when people sit down and they
go,
I see you in a past life and you are
handmade and you,
you,
you work by the river,
get the fuck outta here.
I think that's all bullshit.
I think those people are nuts and
there's a lot
of people that want to think they're
special and they want to think that they
have special gifts in there.
Everybody does.
People get really good at reading
people.
I know people who are professional
magicians and they are expert cold
readers.
I could sit down with you and breed and
tell you remarkable amounts of things
with your,
about your life,
just with your answers to questions,
but they'll tell you right away.
They're not psychic.
Like there's a guy named bandit check
who's excellent at it.
He's fantastic.
He does a show in Vegas and he freaks
people out because he'll tell you right
away,
I am not a psychic.
He's like,
this is a,
there's techniques to this and it's
something I've been doing my whole life,
and you just get really good at it and
he knows how to do it.
And these people are con artists.
They're,
they're con artists.
They trick you into thinking that they
have,
but they might even believe it
themselves.
That's part of the problem.
A lot of those people calm themselves,
but I think there is something like when
you're thinking about someone and they
call you like out of nowhere and you
haven't talked,
the prevalence of synchronicities that
pop up in your life,
you're like,
oh my God,
I was thinking about that movie and
there it is on TV.
Yeah.
It's entirely possible that there is
some bizarre connection that we don't
totally understand to events into people
and into things
well like attracts like or where
attention goes,
energy flows.
Yeah.
There's probably a lot to that.
Certain magnetism to those two things
that bring it together.
Yes,
maybe,
but I think it's very,
very poorly understood and there's a lot
of woo that's clouding it up and that
woo gets in the way of rational,
logical,
educated people.
Even considering it,
they dismiss it instantaneously because
it's connected to somebody,
assholes with neon signs.
It's a card reader,
palm reader,
and these people that just,
they're just ripping you off.
That's all they're doing.
They don't have a real job.
They sit down,
they talk to people for a job and you
know,
you could say it's entertainment.
He could say that what they're doing is
they're providing you with a service
that serves as they sit down with you
and,
and maybe by telling you that
everything's going to be amazing.
You'll walk out of there with a lot of
enthusiasm and then life will be
amazing.
Who knows?
You believe that if you think your
life's going to be amazing,
it will be no,
no.
You get hit by a meteor given me a lot
kind of the house.
You could fall into a crack in the
ground from an earthquake.
I mean,
well those people that died in the
tsunami in Thailand did,
were they bad people?
No.
There was there any level of Wu that's
worth following through on?
I think it's all things.
I think some,
some of the connections and the
intuition and some superstitions and
ideas that we have are probably based in
this limited understanding that we have
in the connection that we have two
events and humans in life.
But I think there's also bullshit
involved too.
And all these things get very cloudy.
I don't think there's an absolute,
but I think it's,
it's entirely possible that intuition is
a developing sense that we don't totally
have yet.
I think if you think about all the
things that people can do,
hearing and seeing and touching and
smelling and all the different senses
that we have,
we,
that that covers the full gamut of
possibilities.
But I don't think that's true.
No,
no,
I think you're right.
And I mean,
even just visually,
you know,
we don't see the full spectrum of what
we see a very,
very small amount of things that are out
there.
Yeah.
And our audio as well,
you know,
we can't hear all the sounds.
Yeah.
I mean,
since it's entirely possible that
there's more going,
like there's certain people that just
have a weird feel to them.
You meet him,
you're like,
I just gotta get away from this guy.
Yeah.
There's,
there's definitely people that they're
giving off weird feelings and it could
be that your reading their intent and
some sort of a way that you don't see
visually,
but you,
you're recognized by their body language
or it could be a bunch of things.
Yeah.
Plead and run when you met me.
So no,
I appreciate that.
And I know we're probably scheduled to
do this interview so you can
couldn't,
but I was looking forward to this.
Why would I run,
I mean I was,
I was impressed by your intensity,
but I expected that in a way.
I mean I just,
I don't see how you could be a race car
driver and not be anti,
especially be a woman and a race car
driver and not be in touch.
Well that's nothing I even thought about
until I was like 14.
Um,
for the first few ways,
abrasive,
way late in life,
think about being a girl out there.
It wasn't until I had cameras following
me around my schools and stuff that I
was like,
all right,
maybe this is,
and then they start asking you about it.
They're like,
what's it like to be a girl?
You're like,
Shit.
And originally,
I don't know really.
I haven't really thought about that.
Um,
how many other girls do it?
I mean,
there are various girls here and there,
but
like in all of Nascar,
how many women are right or racing?
Oh,
I'm at my level,
not,
yes.
Zero.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Huh?
That's pretty crazy.
I Dunno.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Wow.
Take it from me.
I'm the last year.
What's it like to be a girl in racing?
I'm like,
ah,
well,
I don't really know what it's like to be
a guy.
So,
you know,
I only have my perspective.
That's true.
You know,
I mean,
I don't know,
like being a girl versus a guy.
What's the difference?
I don't know.
What's it like to be a guy?
Uh,
yeah,
it probably be different,
but I think that like,
what's it like to be a woman that's the
only woman who's in Nascar at your
level?
That's,
that's a valid question.
I mean,
that's crazy.
How does,
how does everybody else treat you?
Yeah.
That,
that,
that really is the main question.
I can't answer because I'm not them.
And I write,
I know that,
um,
from,
from enough experience now,
because I used to not really look into
it much.
And then in the indycar days you
couldn't hit each other.
You know,
you really,
I mean it was,
you know,
you could block and things like that.
So there were some guys out there that
were assholes and I didn't like them.
But you know,
sometimes every driver has some dry,
some other drivers that they don't
really get along with.
And so,
but in Nascar you can hit each other and
it's,
you have bumpers and,
um,
which is really cool,
but it also isn't cool because if
somebody wants to do it,
they can.
So what would I say?
I would say that they don't want to get
passed by a girl.
And you know what?
I don't either.
Is that weird?
No,
I really don't.
I mean,
I've driven,
I've raced with girls and I don't,
I don't like it.
So do you,
do you feel differently when a
guy passes you then when a girl passes
you probably,
yeah.
Yes.
In what way?
Well,
you know,
she'll just go internally.
That bitch,
I'm like,
can't believe my car isn't faster.
Right.
This sucks.
But it was a guy that passed stories
that are not good that I'm like,
you know,
come on the radio and I'd be like,
ah,
yeah,
I just want you to see that what car
passed me and how bad my car is out now.
Right now I'm,
so it happens with guys too.
But you know,
I don't know.
It's just a cultural norm that girls
aren't good and allow,
you know,
aren't very good and that they,
they,
um,
somewhat don't belong.
And I get like the little bit of
animosity at first,
but I would have thought that people
would have got,
got used to it a little bit more than
they did.
So,
but you have that cultural and Masa,
you were saying a little bit.
Yeah,
it comes from,
but when you say that it's a,
it's a cultural norm that girls aren't
good.
You don't think about that about
yourself?
No.
Yeah.
See,
I knew that.
Oh,
there's,
you don't have any doubts.
No,
I get everyone out there.
I'm like,
you suck because of this and I'm going
to beat you because of that and right.
Oh God,
I hate you.
I don't think because I'm a girl,
I'm not as good as,
no,
not at all.
So why would you think that about the
other girl?
I don't know.
I just did it cause I'm not used to it.
Right.
You just something you're not used to.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
And we'll also,
it's like you're unique.
I mean,
what if you were out there in the gym
and some girl comes and picks up more
weight than you and you're like,
oh,
that's weird.
I'll be like that pitches on roids.
She probably would be,
but Amazon freak,
some genetic freak.
I tried to sign her.
Bring it to you.
Oh yeah,
no kidding.
Do you know?
Throw a punch.
Yeah.
Uh Huh.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I think,
um,
I think we all have a cultural
prejudices.
Yeah.
To a certain extent.
Whether we admit it or not.
And,
you know,
maybe you're not a big,
it maybe you're just maybe just have
reservations and you're pleasantly
surprised when people surpass those
expectations.
Yeah.
You know,
but I would think that a,
you would experience probably more
discrimination as a woman.
Uh,
then,
I mean,
if you think about a woman doing almost
any other job,
like if you're telling me you're the
only woman that does that and you're at
this intense macho job,
this is a fucking intense job.
I mean,
you'd going 200 miles an hour.
Everybody's,
it's nuts.
That's a crazy job.
And you're out there at the top of the
food chain with all these men.
Yeah,
I would,
I would imagine there's two things that
happen.
There's a bunch of guys they treat you
with respect there.
They're like,
wow.
They're like impress.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're cool with you.
They're like,
she's one of us.
That's right.
And then there's a few that are just
dicks and the those dicks or just
encourageable.
Mm Man.
The amount of times I wish I was good at
taking people out.
I wish people knew how hard it was to
actually take someone out on track.
It's not that easy.
You would cause you can risk taking
yourself.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And if your car doesn't handle very
well,
you can't get close enough to him.
If you could,
you would just move the air,
which is almost like hitting him and get
him out of the way.
But sometimes the car doesn't handle
well enough,
so like you'd have to just bomb in there
and God willing,
you hit them to get you to slow down and
then these go sailing and you keep
going.
But it's risk.
That's a rare moment,
right?
Yeah.
Have you done it before?
I've tried to take people.
I suck at it,
absolutely suck at it.
I've taken myself out like three times
trying to do it.
I mean,
look,
I'll be the lamb.
I don't mind it to make a point.
Um,
yeah.
I got to make a point of someone's
driving like a dick.
Yeah.
So what was the one that was the most
sad was,
um,
uh,
it was a couple of years ago was at
Martinsville and this is when something
was going down with,
it was Matt Kenseth and Joey Logano and
it was during the chase,
which is the last 10 races of the
season.
And they were in the chase,
Matt and Joey and Joey had made it so
that Matt couldn't get in,
cause he took them out of week earlier
week or two earlier and then they got to
Martinsville and it's a very,
very small short track.
It's just a half a mile.
And so it,
it's easy to kind of be able to attack
if you want to.
And so he just straight took them out
and um,
there was a whole big hoopla about it.
People up in arms thought it was totally
unfair and um,
anyway,
during the same race,
some asshole hits me,
takes,
spins me out and so I come back and I'm
a lap down or something cause he spins
me out and I go to take him out and I
just sail off into the corner.
He manages to kind of keep going.
I spin again because I'm horrible at it.
And uh,
it turns out that,
you know,
I get up $50,000 fine because I am,
um,
I'm not racing for position because I
was a lap down.
Um,
and they applied that because that was
also the same race that Matt and Joey
had their big thing.
And I think maybe joey was leading or
something like,
I think he was leading and it was on a
restart.
Um,
so they weren't racing for position
either.
So that was kind of like their rule that
they put forth to make for,
I mean,
Joe,
Matt probably got a hundred or $200,000
fine,
but I'm there.
I am,
you know,
not the,
I'm definitely screwed in this scenario.
So I got fined 50 grand for it and I'm
the one that's out
the other guy.
If you're racing for position,
then it's okay to bump into each other
apparently.
Yes.
So really you're the one that screwed.
Because if you're racing,
if someone takes you out and then you're
still racing for position,
now you're going to have to be
potentially,
you know,
putting yourself in another position to
get taken out when they started it.
It's a no win for the person that's
being aggressed the aggressor.
Was it always legal to bump into each
other?
Uh,
it's gone kind of through waves of
different rules,
but yeah,
I mean it is legal,
but when,
whenever a big accident happens and
there's a tragedy,
I would assume that that's when they
tightened down the rules.
Mm hmm.
Sometimes,
sometimes not.
Sometimes you just accept
that it's just happened.
Sometimes it's just usually if there's
something like that that happens,
it's not from one person's action that
it's maybe a chain of events that leads
to something like that.
It's one of the rare jobs that you do
that's a sport,
one of the rare sports where the
potential for death is always there.
Yeah,
it's true.
It is true.
Does that one of the reasons why you
decided
I am,
I'm not a daredevil.
Like I am not a daredevil.
I went bungee jumping and that is the
bravest thing I've ever done otherwise.
And I only did it because I am afraid of
heights.
So I just needed to know that if I had
to conquer a fear,
I could.
Well,
what's your definition of a daredevil?
Your your briefings or you could
potentially get hurt.
I'm not though.
That's true.
Yeah,
but you're a race car driver,
but I'm a methodical driver.
I'm methodical.
I don't go out there and just,
you know,
hold it wide open until the car does
something and then I'm like up better
lift now.
I'm like,
I'm a thoughtful drivers,
so I build up what I think what you're
saying is you're not stupid.
Ah,
that's very nice of you.
That's like a really,
really nice way to say that.
Yeah.
You're not dumb,
but you're definitely a daredevil.
Thank you.
Well,
I'm have to be.
I'm not,
there's no way you can not be.
I'm just not,
I'm serious.
That really knows me,
knows that I'm not brave.
Oh Wow.
That's so crazy.
I know.
I think you're talking crazy,
crazy talk over here.
Well,
you know,
it's true.
I just have been grooming this talent
since I was 10 and 26 years later.
I'm,
I'm okay with it.
I think it's both of those things,
but I think there's no doubt that you're
a brave person,
isn't it?
Actually my first time in a go kart was
horrible.
Well,
you three,
10,
10 and my sister was eight.
My Dad built the go carts.
There's a big parking lot out back.
So we got like spray cans,
wd Fort,
whatever,
pop cans,
I don't know.
Whatever.
Yeah.
I grew up in the Midwest,
so pop,
um,
and set them up in a big circle for my
sister and I to go out and drive around,
drive our go carts for the first time.
And um,
my dad made,
there was a little mistake with the
brake pedal and so it stopped working.
And um,
since I'm 10 and I'm s really young and
dumb and I don't know what I'm doing,
young,
dumb and broke,
I guess I was,
yeah,
like the song goes.
Um,
but I,
uh,
I went to hit the break,
it wasn't there,
so instead of just spinning out or
continuing to turn,
I just went straight and I was headed
for,
um,
trailer,
like kind of a higher elevated trailer,
which would have resulted in
decapitation.
And I swerved at the last second and hit
a concrete wall and I like go flying and
my arm lays back on the,
on the muffler and my cool puffy jacket
burns.
And like I bruises all up my legs and on
my arms.
And,
um,
that was my first time in a go kart
within,
you know,
five or 10 minutes of being out there.
And so,
um,
my dad just got a new one and built it
and we went racing.
So maybe I am really brave.
I don't know.
You're right.
Maybe it's,
I always felt like an indy car to some
degree.
I wasn't brave because people were
willing to do things that were
perceivably more brave.
But I also,
I did describe them as dumb.
You're right.
Yeah.
So you're probably a little right.
And I'm maybe a little right too,
but you're right.
I think you definitely brave,
but I think there's definitely a line
where bravery becomes stupid because the
risk outweighs the reward 100% yeah.
That's a masculine thing.
And a lot of ways because it's
testosterone makes you do really stupid
shit.
Does it won't.
They're all competing against each other
and the trying to out macho each other.
I mean,
you could go,
there's,
there's a bunch of twitter accounts so
you can go and see what's that one,
hold this beer.
Yeah.
Has a twitter account called hold my
beer while all these,
well,
exactly why I do everything.
It's like jumping off roofs and stupid
shit.
And it's almost all men.
There's occasionally a drunk girl doing
something stupid,
but it's almost entirely men.
So I would think that men trying to out
macho with each other
somewhat inferior then because they do a
lot of dumb stuff.
Maybe their hormones are not in balance
like ours.
They definitely,
when competing against each other,
we'll do dumb shit.
That's an interest around drones to
blame.
Well,
they try to out macho each other.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I mean some don't.
Some are smart and they don't,
but you know,
there's just a part of being a man.
It's like trying to prove that you're
not scared as part of being a man.
Tell me about men.
What do you wanna know
now?
What else is,
what else is a very manly that women
don't understand?
What,
what,
what don't women understand about men?
That's a good question.
I have no idea what you understand about
us.
Hmm.
Maybe just speak from experience.
Yeah.
But I don't,
I don't know what,
like if we ask a guy like what's wrong?
Oh,
see that's just nonsense.
Talk.
See that's the like,
what's Rani?
Girls out there like,
well honey,
what's wrong?
What's wrong?
And they're like nothing.
Sometimes it's not really,
is it really nothing?
Yeah.
Sometimes you just want me to like
decompress.
Okay.
You know,
sometimes it just wound it.
Is that annoying when a girl does that?
Depends on the girl,
you know?
What do you mean?
Depends on the girl.
If she's annoying,
yeah,
it's annoying.
But if you're in love with her and she's
awesome and she can ask what's wrong,
nothing.
We're good.
Yeah.
It depends on the time.
The right one.
Oh,
100% that's 100% yeah.
If someone's asking you questions and
you're getting really fucking annoyed,
it's probably not the question.
It's probably more the person.
If you think someone's amazing and they
ask you something stupid,
you'll just laugh.
You won't get annoyed.
And you guys get both joke around about
how stupid it was,
how the question was dumb.
All right,
that's good.
You get angry.
It's most likely you're just like,
I know it anyway.
Yeah.
So you're just like ready to ready to
ready to sort of fall over that annoying
and to get out.
Get out of my space.
Kind of a attitude.
Cause you're already annoyed with them
anyway.
You're already don't really like him.
Yeah.
There's probably something that's
already rubbing you the wrong way and
you're tolerating each other instead of
enjoying each other.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would imagine a person like you,
a very intense person,
you probably have a difficult time
finding.
You know,
like if you get a square peg in a square
hole and everything slides in together,
perfect.
And everything's amazing personality
wise,
you know,
behavior wise,
I would imagine what something like you
look,
it's a very particular,
you have to find someone who appreciates
your intensity,
right?
Yeah.
Like a lot of times guys are,
they want a demure,
you know,
sort of like docile little creature.
Whatever you need,
I'll be home.
Well,
he on the table here when you get back,
right?
I mean,
while you're out there with a fucking go
car going 150 miles an hour in the
driveway.
Yep.
That's,
Run in five businesses.
Yeah.
You're going 200.
So if you're saying what's wrong,
the guys like fucking nothing.
Probably a bunch of other shit that's
really wrong.
It's very insightful.
Yeah.
All right,
so what,
what don't men understand about women?
Um,
she's tapping her fingers,
going through it.
Everything.
Yeah.
I mean,
I just think that we'd like to be,
you know,
we like to be told what you're thinking.
I do.
I like to know what someone's thinking,
you know,
the whole,
like we're just,
you know,
just keeping it to myself.
Like,
tell me about it.
I want to know what your self is
thinking about.
I want to know about you.
What's going through your head?
Like communication
now,
is this universal amongst all your
girlfriends when you get together and
talk about,
I would think so.
Yeah.
So the problem is like,
you look at a guy and say,
you know,
you really liked this guy and you're
like,
this fucking dude.
Some crazy mystery.
Like what's going on in your head,
man?
Yeah.
That's not good.
But it out.
Everyone wants to know where they stand
and what someone's thinking.
Oh,
where they stand.
Well,
because and where they stand on what
they're thinking.
Because you know what if the thing about
someone else,
oh,
so he needed,
no,
sorry.
Yeah,
you just need to know if you're all in.
100%
I'm still all in person.
So for me it's not a mystery.
Like you wanna know what's going on in
my head.
I'll tell you right now.
That's intense.
Yeah.
So yeah,
if a guy's like off drifting and you
automatically assume test one of the
fuckers thinking wrong,
somebody else now what are you up to?
Yeah,
and it's,
yeah,
exactly.
You want to be able to ask.
I guess guys probably do that too.
And girls like to hear nice things to
girls like to hear,
you know,
girls like to be,
girls like of course,
you know,
to uh,
be appreciated just like a guy does.
I mean,
I think that's my advice most of the
time in relationships.
I'm like,
sympathy goes a really long way because
I know it goes a long way with me no
matter what facet of my life it is.
But you know,
sympathy goes a long way.
So you know,
if your husband's in a bad mood,
then why don't you just actually start
off with,
instead of feeling like you're under
appreciated going,
hey baby,
look like you've had a really long day
and I'm sure you've been working your
butt off.
Like what can I,
can I make you dinner?
Like what do you want?
What's your favorite?
You know,
and they'll probably go,
oh,
you know what is not that not that big
of a deal.
You know what Babe,
I'm fine.
Hey,
let me take you out to dinner.
I get to eat.
The sympathy gets sympathy back and you
don't,
it's not,
it's not good to do it to get it
necessarily,
but you should really feel like you are
sympathetic.
Like if they're in a bad place,
try and help him.
That's sound advice.
Yeah,
center stage.
Just sympathy because most people go
under appreciate,
especially in a relationship.
I think the longer it goes,
there's a lot of under appreciation and
assumptions that get made about who does
what and checks that box off.
And probably,
especially with kids,
right amounts,
you're with kids,
it gets way worse.
It's just,
there's a lot of time that's involved
with taking care of those little
suckers.
You got to pay attention to them and
talk to them and they,
and if you have more than one,
like once you start talking to one,
the other one wants to just chime in,
you know,
and show you what they're doing.
Like,
wait,
I was busy just trying to make sure you
don't die.
Now I gotta deal with this.
Yeah.
I think people get used to things,
you know,
and that's,
that's part of the problem.
They get used to each other.
Yeah.
They do.
And then,
and then,
you know,
it's like,
I always tell people,
aspire to be the person you pretend to
be when you're trying to get laid.
If you could be that person all the
time,
you will have a much better life.
I also love the expression for every hot
chick,
there's a dude sickest.
Groner.
Yeah.
I don't say it that way,
but yes,
I use more flavorful language,
but yeah.
Is that,
was that too much or too little?
Too Little?
How would you say it?
Uh,
for every hot chick,
there's a guy somewhere that's tired of
fucking her.
Okay.
That's how you'd say it,
but yeah,
I mean I guess but that's not entirely
true either.
I mean it's for the most part,
a lot of the times it's true,
but a lot of the times people don't
appreciate for circumstance.
Exactly,
and then it's with various aspects of
your life,
like I always feel like that.
Like I just got over the flu a week and
a half ago.
I had the flu and I was sick for like
two days and then when I was sick I was
thinking,
man,
I don't appreciate how good I feel when
I'm healthy because here I am line here.
I'll aiken watching netflix feeling like
shit going,
wow,
what?
I'm healthy and I'm working out and I'm
running and doing Jujitsu and all the
activities and I got all this energy and
I feel great.
Like I just can't do anything right now.
I just take it for granted.
You do forget the joy of just being
healthy.
It just escapes us.
We just so think it's normal because
most of the time you granted,
Yup.
Now,
do you think that your stepping away
from race car driving when you deciding
just like enough is enough?
Do you think that in some ways that this
is,
you appreciating other aspects of life
too,
that you are,
you're,
you're
looking at your racing thing and you're
like,
you know what,
I did a lot,
I did enough and then why don't I just
appreciate all the other stuff?
Well,
I think that's a good question.
A leading me into a good thought.
Like,
um,
I think it's actually more me being
honest.
Like I think everyone would expect since
I do what I do at the level that I do it
at,
that racing is my only thing I care
about.
I love it so much.
I'll do anything I drive every day.
And the truth is no,
I like racing,
but I don't,
there's a lot of things I don't really
like about it too and I'm grateful for
everything it's given me.
But if you were to ask me what I do
outside of racing and my personal life,
I don't go to the race track.
I don't really watch races.
I don't,
I don't do that.
So those aren't my hobbies.
Like your hobbies or your real loves,
what do you not like about it?
Um,
well I would say that in the last year
or so,
the,
just the,
as far as an energetic space,
it's just so sad and negative at times.
A lot of the time.
And even in just racing in general,
most of the time it's miserable.
Like you have some days that are good,
but most of the time it's not happy and
you wish there was,
you're,
um,
you're not satisfied.
You wish somebody would have treated you
better out there.
You,
there's so many things to be negative
about and just the grind of it.
Um,
it's the people,
like everybody's worn out and you know,
you have to be really careful about the
people that are around you because they
got to be in a good mood because it's
easy to spiral out of control because
you see each other for three,
four days a week,
every week for 40 weeks a year.
So,
you know,
you got to be in a good space with
people,
but it's still doesn't alienate you
completely.
Even if there,
you're in a good space with people,
the ones next to you,
cause you've got a car next to you on
both sides in the garage and haulers
next to each other and buses right next
to each other and you see a bunch of
other people.
So,
you know,
it was just,
I dunno,
there's a lot of negativity to some
degree.
Um,
a lot of grind.
It just kinda feels like the grind a
little bit.
Um,
and um,
so I just kind of felt like it wasn't a
space that I wanted to be in as much
anymore.
Like,
I,
I want to be in a happy space where I'm
just doing things that bring me joy and
um,
yeah,
it just,
there wasn't doing that as much or I was
noticing it,
I was noticing I was missing that or
wanting it more.
I think that's really what it comes from
is growing as a person and realizing,
um,
I think everybody's afraid to take
chances and do something new in their
life because they're identified a
certain way or there'll be judged if
they don't do it or judged if they do
something different and who are they now
and are they crazy and what are they
thinking?
And you know,
it's just life.
Just do things that make you happy.
It's interesting because you're talking
about this and the negative aspects of
it as all interpersonal relationships
and so talking to people,
you're not talking about that the grind
of racing itself,
like the heat of being in the car and
the strain and the intensity and the
nerves.
You're not talking about it.
Yeah,
I didn't,
not the first thing.
I mean,
that is,
that exists on some level,
but I mean that's,
that's fine.
I work out,
I work out twice a day,
a lot of time,
a lot of times.
So I'm okay with the whole like physical
grind of things.
Yeah.
What do you do?
Crossfit and like interval running,
training,
sprinting,
um,
stuff like that.
Circuits toys or volt stuff.
Yeah.
A couple of days a week.
I do twice a day.
Maybe more intensity.
Yeah.
Very intense for sure.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the name of the game and get it,
get in,
get out.
Um,
so,
uh,
so yeah,
so I mean that,
that is part of it.
The physical part of racing exists and
it is exhausting,
but I mean,
you recover from that every weekend.
Um,
but yeah,
it's,
yeah,
it's just,
and I just love so many other things.
What are you going to do now?
Um,
well,
the longest project I have is my wine.
Um,
I bought the property in 2009,
planted a vineyard and it's finally for
sale.
Um,
so,
um,
so it's called,
started in 2009.
So nine years bought the property,
planted.
It started from nothing.
So,
um,
it came from a,
in 2006,
I went to Napa valley on a,
on a trip and was on this beautiful
property and just like looking at the
fog and the valley and it was wonderful
Keesha's and fruits for breakfast and
this amazing white wine.
And I was like,
man,
it'd be so cool if I could have
something like this someday,
but I don't have $50 million,
at least not right now anyway.
And um,
cause I never abandoned the thought that
I would be able to afford that someday.
I just didn't,
I couldn't then.
Um,
so anyway,
I just started the process of different
way.
I didn't buy a wine that was built and
established for the vineyard.
I bought dirt,
planted the vineyard.
How do you go about doing that?
Do you hire someone?
Uh,
well I,
that that day I met I winemaker who
ended up going into consulting instead
of just being at one winery and I'm,
so he actually helped me pick the
property.
He's still my winemaker today.
So you,
you buy this piece of land and then like
who does the day to day stuff?
You're so busy.
Yeah,
I have a gm now,
um,
who handles all of it and does the
promotion and gets it in restaurants and
you know,
s you know,
help sell it.
What's it called?
Omnium,
which is a Latin world,
Latin word means dream.
I was looking at some language
translations trying to come up with,
I was probably trying to come up with
some sort of an llc or something like
that to cover the property up.
And I was like,
oh no,
this is way too cool.
This is what should the wine should be
called?
Um,
so Somnio I'm,
it's a Latin word.
And Are you doing red and white or red
to start?
Um,
the only,
the vineyard is cabernet cab franc,
petite for doe.
And um,
so from the cab franc in petite or doe
bleed off,
we're going to make a rose a this year.
Um,
and then we also then source some grapes
from Knight's Valley to make a 70 old
blank.
Um,
so we,
um,
we just decided it was going to come out
in the spraying along with the,
with the cab or early release and the
um,
and the,
and the rosy,
but it needed some time in barrel.
So we're going to wait a little longer
and put it in barrel.
That's fascinating.
So that much take a shit load of your
time and thinking as well.
Honestly,
that's probably the least amount of my
time really that company.
But I would imagine if you have this
giant investment,
you've got the skull,
it's a giant investment,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Do you have someone working for you?
They're growing grapes,
two employees and um,
um,
uh,
farmers that farm,
it's not full.
I mean they farm many other properties,
but um,
but yeah.
Were you affected at all by the crazy
fires and no,
actually I was really lucky that the
Napa valley fires were,
um,
I'm on Silverado trail side up.
It's actually very,
very close to how mountain appalachian,
but it's,
I'm like,
like 60 feet off of being home out in
the Appalachian.
So anyway,
way down south on Silverado trail there
was fire and then straight across the
valley.
Not too far laterally across,
but it was all the way across the valley
was the fires on the other side.
So I was about as far away from it all
is I could get.
And so I just talked to my wine maker,
I'm a few days ago and um,
he said that there's really nothing,
no residual from any of the fires or
anything.
So that's amazing.
Like with my wine.
Anyway,
so,
so that whole area,
it's such a bummer that fire was in the
same,
oh my gosh,
I just thought it was going,
I forget the exact number,
but it was something in insane,
like it was going a football field
distance in three seconds,
like at its peak.
I know that the bigger,
I think the big reason was the wind came
in that night,
like 40 plus mile an hour winds came
through that night.
Very,
very,
very devastating for some.
Uh,
but that's one company.
Um,
the clothing line is called warrior.
so that came out a year ago,
January of last year of 17.
Wow.
Uh,
when
is it like affliction,
like skulls and swords and shit?
No.
Is the warrior jacket I have on,
it's very nice.
Thanks.
Lovely.
Um,
no,
it's more athleisure.
Um,
so leisure,
leisure,
have you never heard of that leisure?
No.
Oh yeah.
It's a whole,
yeah,
there you go.
Thanks.
Um,
I just saw like a 17 year old.
it's,
yeah,
it's like leggings and sports bras and
tee shirts and jackets and sweatshirts
and,
yeah,
as Felicia [inaudible].
So,
uh,
I want to go back to this wine thing.
Oh,
so you have this thought in your and
abroad?
Yeah.
Well I'll go buy some,
tell me where I can get it.
Can you get it anywhere?
Right?
Omnium wine.com.
It's not sold in very many places and
mostly online it's not,
there's not very much made,
so,
oh,
okay.
So you can order it online and you guys
will ship it.
Okay.
So now you,
you get this piece of property and you
start talking to this guy.
He was a consultant and you started
talking about making wine,
like what is the process like how does
it,
you,
you have to,
you buy the property and then how do you
get the seeds?
How do you get the right grapes?
How do you know?
Well,
you have to go through a bunch of 'em
permitting.
Um,
so permitting for,
uh,
plans for it.
Uh,
there's a certain grades that are not.
So if it's over 20 degrees grade,
then you have to have special approvals,
but under you can plant.
So I literally planted six acres ish of
Max.
It's the Max that I could plant on my 24
acres that I have that was below 20
degree grade.
And so,
um,
so,
uh,
you have to go through erosion control
permitting because it's,
you know,
the slopes and if you're going to dig up
the ground,
you don't want it to slide down the
mountain if it rains.
So we had to kind of get creative with
some of the,
uh,
infrastructure to dissipate the water.
And so it didn't create just rivers and
rushing of,
you know,
new dirt sliding down the hill.
So,
um,
cause it's al Asad elevation a little
bit.
Um,
so,
um,
and then you hire farmers and then the
winemaker helps pick out the root stock
and the clones and then they plan it and
you wait a couple of years for it to be
ready and then they start making wine.
So it starts with clones,
which is route stops first.
Oh,
root stock.
And then what does he graft on the clone
that they want?
What's a root stock?
Like the actual route.
Yeah,
that would be,
I wish I knew every single thing that
you're asking to the nth degree,
but I mean that would be like Cabernet,
petite verdot white wine,
right.
Whatever.
I'm sure that there,
when they did all this,
I,
no,
I want to see what that is.
That sounds fascinating.
Tiny little tiny little roots.
Yeah.
Trellising up.
And then,
you know,
then you get into,
depending on your wine maker,
they decide then how much fruit to drop.
Um,
so,
um,
sort of the,
the vine comes up and splits off and
makes like a tea.
Um,
and so they decide how many clusters
they keep on each side to determine,
you know,
what kind of wine you're making.
So,
you know,
we drop a lot of fruit to make really
good.
Yeah.
What does that mean by drop fruit?
Like you'd lose literally cut the cut
the cluster off of the vine.
So you,
yeah,
that's why I like if you're buying bulk
wine,
it's they're not dropping a damn thing.
Right,
right.
If you're buying grapes,
they're also not dropping a damn thing
or,
well,
not as much probably because there,
um,
because they're there,
they're there.
You're paying by the ton.
So this is a long process.
Oh,
it's a really long process to go nine
years from the time you start to making
your first bottles.
Probably why most people,
you know,
I mean,
if you have enough money to build a
winery,
you're probably a bit older and like you
run out of time.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean especially,
You're going to get any return on your
investment.
You know,
I'm a lot of millions in the hole,
but you know,
whatever,
it's a passion project.
Are you doing it as an investment?
Are you doing it because you
love it?
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
I can
cause you can,
yeah.
Why not do what you can.
Yeah.
Just money.
And I love the lifestyle.
So I want to share that with people.
You know,
our style Nafa
wine,
you know,
the connection that you create,
sitting down together and sharing it.
Um,
the stories of the vineyard,
the story of how it came along.
I mean,
I have,
the good thing is,
is people were like,
well,
you gotta have a story.
I'm like,
well,
I have a story,
but that's what people connect to.
So,
um,
that's,
you know,
so then it's a matter of getting that
story to the psalms in different
restaurants so that they can tell you
the story of Somnio them and then,
you know,
you're like,
oh,
that sounds amazing.
No,
that's hers.
That's so cool.
Like,
I would love it if my wine was a good
story that someone told.
And then they were like,
oh,
and this is the actually Danica Patrick
swine.
And you're like,
oh,
no way.
Yeah.
I got to try that.
You know what I mean?
I'd rather have that be the backstory.
Then the front story.
Do you know,
um,
maynard teen and from tool to know?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I've drank his wine before.
Could he see us?
Caduceus could do see us?
Yes.
I have some.
It's in my fridge right now.
Got it a long time ago.
Got it up in a jerome,
jerome,
Arizona.
He has a little cellar door in jerome.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I've never met him.
I tried to meet him and I bawled.
I was like,
eh,
but it didn't.
He's actually in town I think.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I think he's still here.
He was just,
he was here yesterday for sure.
Yeah.
He starts to some of his grapes from
California,
I think for som is wine.
Yeah.
He did a similar thing,
but he did it in Arizona.
Yes.
He just bought this land and then
develop it for salmon,
Arizona,
but the red,
I think the better red came from
California.
Is that what he's a freak.
He's a real crazy person.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
In what way?
Super Intelligent.
Just super,
super smart,
like too smart,
too smart to talk to most people.
He's just so out there and an intense as
well.
And maybe it's something to do with,
you know,
the,
the choices.
So he,
I mean,
he's a lead singer,
three fucking bands and then says,
you know what?
Yeah.
And then let me,
let me just start making my own wine.
Yeah.
Opened up a restaurant.
Like he's just,
he can't do enough shit.
He does Jujitsu all the time.
Can't do it.
I'm sure you guys know him.
Yeah.
And he was over here for Jujitsu to,
um,
uh,
seminars.
John,
Donna her.
He was at one of his seminars.
Yes sir.
Oh yeah.
No,
he's a maniac.
Weirdos make wine then.
I think so.
Well,
I think I'd rather be weird than normal.
I think that's a good way of looking at
things.
It's nothing wrong with being word
normal.
Unconventional,
or the opposite of where I looked it up.
I don't want to be either of those.
Yeah.
Well,
it depends,
you know,
conventional wisdom is not bad.
It said conventional.
Yeah.
There's,
there's some normal that's not bad.
You know,
I like normal cheeseburgers,
you know,
I don't see,
I want caramelized onions.
I want to Friday I want Maple Bacon.
Ah,
you're a pain in the ass.
I love food.
Like I love food.
I ate more than most everyone.
Yes.
Yeah.
But your tiny,
well you put it away.
Well you work out twice a day.
Some days I didn't work out today.
It didn't work out.
It didn't work out to work out.
But um,
yeah,
I do eat a lot.
My sister and I both do,
we're both like
110 tenish pounds and
we are both like five foot and we both
eat a ton,
but we work at what you do,
where we do work out a little
hummingbirds,
hey you all that energy,
you're burning off pro burning calories
council.
We look at each other and were like,
I would die without fat.
I need a lot of fat in my diet.
Yeah.
Um,
maynard open up a restaurant to an
awesome yeah,
no in,
in Arizona.
Hmm.
So,
so sort of feature is wines
and where,
uh,
where in Arizona,
because I know Joe's jerome is pretty
far from like,
I mean I might have,
my place is in Scottsdale,
so yeah,
he's out in the middle of nowhere.
He's uh,
his vineyards.
Jerome.
Yeah.
I think it's in that era.
Homes on the top of a mountain.
I mean this is a,
this is a cool place to go if you're
ever visiting Arizona.
Jerome is really interesting.
You kind of wind up this mountain,
you get up to the top.
It's like supposedly all haunted and
it's very bizarre.
Um,
but there's,
yeah,
he,
I mean the last I knew it was a very
long time ago that I was there.
Um,
but it,
um,
it,
uh,
he has a cool cellar door and there's
some restaurants and whatnot and it's on
top of a mountain.
Yeah,
that's,
that's maynard.
That's the kind of thing he's into.
And he's very wise to about balancing
out the rock star life versus like,
that's one of the things that I think
was attractive to him about creating a
wine.
I'd say that's really important.
I mean I've,
I think I've feel like I've figured out
in my life how much grounding I need to
balance me out.
And it's not like,
it's not just like everybody needs 50,
50,
you know,
it's been 50% of the time walking around
in the woods and 50% of the time doing
your shit.
It's,
you know,
everybody's different.
So for me it's like,
you know,
maybe 20% of the time I need to take a
walk in nature or do a yoga class or
meditate or something like that.
Yeah.
Do you feel like,
do you need decompression time just from
the whole celebrity thing,
just being interviewed and media and
people paying attention to you want to
take pictures with you?
They'll just,
the constant assault.
I don't feel it's exhausting because I'm
listening and I'm paying attention.
I'm answering your questions honestly.
Where I think most people can just go
into sort of like autopilot mode and
it's probably not as mentally exhausting
for them.
Um,
I need,
for me,
it's just being on,
you know what I mean?
Right.
Like you just have to be on all the
time.
You know?
Um,
so the,
the being on part is nice to get away
from.
Yeah,
I was,
so,
it's kind of answering the questions,
but it's really just a matter of having
to like,
you know,
navigating life and people staring at
you or wanting something from you or
thinking they want something from you
just because you're trained,
because too many people have wanted
something from you.
Right.
Um,
to,
you know,
just the demands of the things that
you're doing and running around.
I mean,
I,
okay,
I'm on an airplane twice a week doing
stuff,
so it's,
you just get exhausted from that.
Yeah.
That's not unhealthy either,
right?
Mm.
Oh.
Do you feel like you're going to step
away from public life when you stopped
racing?
Do you gonna Fade into the problem?
Normalcy?
No,
I don't think so.
No.
I'd love to have a cooking show,
so a cooking show,
like I said,
I love cooking.
Yeah.
I'm a,
I'm like,
what kind of stuff?
Anything.
I'm not much of a baker though.
That's because I'm a free spirit and
baking is all down to a science.
You're like,
measure everything.
It's gotta be a certain temperature and
I'm one of those.
Just dump it in a bowl.
Tasted does it need more sugar?
Does it need more acid as Nabi when
we're rich with fat,
does it need spice?
Does it need,
what does it need?
No.
Are you going off of books d take
classes?
Like how'd you,
how'd you learn how to cook?
Well,
when I moved to England,
when I was 16,
I live by myself eventually.
Why did you do that?
Why'd you move to England to race?
You were racing in England?
Yeah,
I left high school and I was 16 and
moved to England and then I,
I lived there for three years.
How do you parents handle that?
I think my mom cried a lot.
I couldn't imagine but they couldn't.
Um,
you know,
they also couldn't imagine me not having
the opportunity so they let me go and I
left high school.
So kind of racing.
Were you doing there?
The lowest level open wheel racing.
So what's that mean?
Open wheel just means that the wheels
are exposed really.
Okay.
Versus stock cars,
which are Nascar.
I'm so open wheel wheel is open.
Um,
so there was no wings on the cars that I
was driving over there at that point in
time.
So it was just,
you know,
no wing open wheel cars.
So I was just,
you know,
starting my,
starting my career really.
Cause from go-carts I will,
I didn't want to be a professional go
drivers.
So I,
I was like,
I'll just get into cars as soon as I
can.
How'd this come up?
Well I was 14 and I was at the
Indianapolis Motor speedway and I went
into a suite and there was some British
dude in there.
And so I started asking about cars and
again,
we're at the race track.
Um,
and this,
this family that he works for has a
team,
has a race team.
And so I guess I asked all the right
questions.
And,
um,
two years later,
when I was 16,
they asked me and my dad to come back to
indy and meet with them and talk about
going over to England a race.
And they said I could learn more in one
year in England,
then five years in America.
And it was not true at all,
but I did it anyway.
Um,
English people please.
Crazy pompous.
No,
get the fuck out of here.
I'm,
I might make England people from England
mad,
but there's not many that I've liked.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I love English people the opposite.
I maybe it was just my environment.
Like they,
that no one,
no one kept in touch after I left and
lived there for three years and no one
kept in touch with me at all.
Hmm.
Maybe you were too intense for English
people.
Hmm.
Well they also have like,
like this is where you are and this is
where you stay.
You have like a very like rigid class
butchers there.
Oh,
well amy.
Yeah.
I have friends that moved to California
from England and they are like,
the people over here are so much more
optimistic about it.
An open minded,
right.
Like,
I mean,
just like bring you in and prove me
wrong.
Instead of like prove to me,
I gotta be your friend.
You know,
it's kind of a European mentality.
A little bit more guarded.
Well,
also being a 16 year old girl,
living there by yourself,
not knowing anybody that had to be
really weird.
I grew a lot.
So I learned more there in one year than
five years in America.
From a personal standpoint.
See,
I went over there and I was very open
and
unguarded and would tell anyone
anything.
And you know,
how'd that work out for it?
It didn't work out very well.
I got hurt a lot.
I hated men after that.
Um,
and uh,
English accents.
Now like when you get from men,
I can obey.
Talk a little bit.
We'll do a little bit.
Yeah,
I'm a little scarred.
Um,
but,
uh,
anyway,
I came home and my parents describe me
as very cold when I came home.
Very guarded,
very cold.
Did you guys visit back and forth
between them?
I would come home like twice a year and
they would come over once or twice a
year.
Oh,
so it wasn't alienation.
Yeah.
Yes.
You know,
but,
but they said you were cold when he got
back.
Yeah.
You became hard.
Yup.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
I know.
Yeah.
One of the hardest things in life is
figuring out who you really are.
Like what you really enjoy,
who you are as a person,
what you stand for instead of what
culture is told you.
What advice do you give someone that's
trying to do that?
Like I have a nephew,
he's a great kid,
but he doesn't know what the fuck he
wants to do.
He's trying to figure it out now.
Yeah,
I mean the first quick couple of things
that you can do to identify what it is
that you're interested in and you know,
something that's true to you as um,
you know,
just what do you do for your hobbies?
That's very insightful.
What do you enjoy doing?
If you were by yourselves,
there's a job for you.
I mean,
isn't it legal here in California now to
sword.
So anyway,
sort of legal,
it's like some guru farmer.
Um,
and then,
uh,
also this is like an odd one,
but look at the phone,
look at the pictures on your phone or
look at the pictures that you post on
social media maybe or something like
that.
But whatever you take pictures is also
kind of pretty insightful for what
you're interested in.
Yeah.
Okay.
You're not taking pictures of stuff that
you don't care about.
No,
it's true.
It's your phone.
What if you're all selfies or pictures?
Like,
well then I think your ego is very loud.
Do you have any selfies on your phone?
So the only,
the only reason why I selfies for me
are,
are Ah,
you're so annoying.
But selfie stick.
No,
no,
no.
But I,
the only way I do them as if I am kind
of promoting,
right.
So for me it's a matter of promoting a
healthy lifestyle.
So maybe it's me in the gym working out.
Maybe it's something like that where I
can be like post a pit,
like whatever workout I did.
And perhaps what you could look like if
you did these workouts sort of sorta.
Maybe better really.
I mean,
um,
so you know,
those are why I would take a selfie or
if it's with someone you really like,
you know,
you can take a picture with someone.
That's something that I don't think that
does that count as a selfie if it's just
you wouldn't be doing someone else.
No,
no.
That's just being creative with how
you're getting a picture of you.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
selfies,
the only time I do it really is,
is pretty much just to promote either
like clothes I'm wearing for my clothing
line or like workout style stuff for my
book.
But for me,
I'm not like,
damn,
my hair looks good today and you know,
I,
I'm like,
Ooh,
look at me and I say nothing.
Yeah,
same.
Let's just,
I don't know,
it's not ego driven.
I know as a woman who is very ambitious
and successful and powerful,
what do you make of these social media
stars now that,
that just do that?
They just stick their butt out and take
pictures and a lot,
a lot of that.
It's a weird
cells.
Yeah.
And always will.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
probably deal with it more emotionally
yourself because it's a vicious circle
where you want more,
so you have to keep doing more.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And you end up dead,
you end up in a place where you don't
know yourself anymore cause you're doing
it to fulfill someone else's wants and
desires more than yours.
Yeah.
Right after going to the next level,
right.
You have to keep your like,
oh I wore this like super cute like
leggings and a sports bra.
Now I got to wear a body suit and now
I'm wearing a thong and only crap.
You know,
like look at me now I'm,
yeah,
what do you do?
What?
Yeah,
who are you and after it like,
but some of it's oddly successful.
It's gone to some of them,
their pages of like 17 million
followers.
Well whoa.
Yeah,
yeah.
Whoa.
I mean,
well what it did of course.
Then it begs the question like what is
your definition of success then?
Yeah.
Cause if you don't make money off 17
million followers,
then what's the point?
I think they do though.
They do like sponsored posts and stuff
like that.
Okay.
I mean I agree.
That's why,
again,
you have to go to the next level all the
time to get more people kind of feeds
the ego's getting fed.
But as a woman who's an attractive woman
who's also very ambitious,
like you could have just been one of
those things,
right?
Like you like
when you see someone,
I mean,
man,
I don't think men look at it this way
because I don't think there's a lot of
guys that like look at guys who just do
like workout instagrams or something
like that and they get look at this
before from God.
How about use your brains protein
powder,
but as a woman who you mean you're not
falling back on your looks is what I'm
trying to say.
It's like you have them but you,
that's just a part of you.
You're obviously hyper ambitious on top
of that.
When you see someone who's just,
do you feel like they're like wasting
time or do you feel like that's just
them?
I just feel like it's immaturity.
Yeah.
I mean,
if that's your driving forces,
just your looks and you know,
but there are some that have some
content,
but you know,
and they can use it to drive a message.
Um,
I mean there's some that I've noticed
like that,
that really do have really positive
messages.
I'm spreading positivity,
spreading good things,
but,
um,
promoting good things.
But,
um,
for those who aren't,
then I just think it's a level of
immaturity.
Um,
and it's going to come to,
I think it will come to bite them
eventually because it's,
where does the road lead to
yeah.
It's a short lived success.
Yeah.
Somebody said this once,
it's a really great quote that beauty is
a short lived tyranny.
Hm.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
kind of leads me to a little bit of a s
one similar,
like the,
I'm not going to get it right,
exactly.
But it's the,
uh,
the ego is impatient because it knows
it's time is limited where the soul is
patient because it,
no,
it has,
it knows it has forever.
Huh.
Ooh,
we should like have memes on like a
stripper's instagram.
Perfect.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Kind of intrusion when the ego needs to
be fed immediately.
You know,
the ego wants something now and it's not
thinking about the long term or it's
true.
No sole decisions are,
you know,
perhaps on realized for a store for an
amount of time.
But you know,
the truth will always come through.
And so if you're not living it,
you're going to have a transition.
Now when you make like a,
if you put like an instagram post up of
workouts and stuff like that,
do you do that specifically because
you're trying to motivate people?
Yeah.
Cause it does for me.
I mean,
when I see somebody hot working out and
see a picture of him,
I'm like,
God,
it there,
get to the gym.
Yeah.
There you get working out.
Oh maybe put that,
put that chocolate down.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think that,
I mean,
people,
especially people in my line of work,
comedians love to mock things along
those lines.
But I take inspiration off of a lot of
people online.
Right.
And I,
you know,
my overwhelm,
like overall what I hope for people too
is that,
um,
with,
with the book I wrote,
I,
I just,
I really want people to find confidence
in themselves and develop a healthier
relationship with food and exercise.
And I think most people think of food as
a punishment,
right?
They're like,
oh my God,
I'll just eat this terrible vegetable.
Or they'll like have to work out the
socks were working out,
can be fun.
Working out can make you feel good.
Food can also make you feel good.
Food is medicine.
Food will make you not only feel good
but be good and I'm look better.
So I'm so,
you know,
I,
I really hope that in all of my
motivation,
it drives people into a direction where
they feel good about it all.
And there's a,
there's,
there's more positivity around it.
Don't you feel like there's so much
negativity around eating healthy and
working out?
There's so many people that just hate
it.
There's quite a bit of that,
but I think there's a lot of positivity
around it too.
I think that people are recognizing more
and more today the benefits of eating
healthy in terms of like psychological
benefits like your,
your mind works better,
physical benefits.
You feel better about your choices.
You feel better about your momentum in
life.
Like,
Hey,
I'm on the right path.
I'm,
I'm healthy,
I'm taking supplements,
I'm working on a regular basis.
My body feels I've got more energy.
It's tuned in.
Right?
I mean,
I remember when I cut out dairy and
gluten years ago and my energy level
finally was up and consistent where
before it'd be like the random day where
you're like,
man,
why am I so exhausted today?
I'm just so tired.
Yeah.
It didn't have any of those days
anymore.
Yeah.
When people eat a lot of refined
carbohydrates and then shift to a diet
that has none of that stuff in it,
it's stunning.
Yeah.
The,
the effect that it has on your mid day.
I always tell people like if do you need
a nap in the middle of the day?
If you're one of those people,
just try,
cut out your sugar,
cut out your refined carbohydrates,
and then watch what happens.
Yeah,
you will.
You will have so much more energy during
the,
not a Napper,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
maybe I like coffee,
but are you one of those four hours of
sleep at night people?
Actually,
I can.
I don't need a lot.
I wake up with the sunlight too,
so I'm one of those people and I wake up
in the morning and like,
I see the light going on.
I'm like,
ah,
it's morning.
Is it morning?
I'm so excited.
If it's morning,
I'm ready.
I love the morning and I'm very chatty
and I'm very like up and ready to go and
like,
are you awake?
Yes.
Are you awake?
You are now me coffee.
Do you want breakfast?
Come on,
let's go rotten.
That's me.
I'm really annoyingly up and ready to go
and happy in the morning.
I love the morning.
How are you at night though?
Sleepy.
Huh?
Okay.
I'm okay.
But once I get horizontal at night,
it's over.
Like I'm falling asleep.
You have no insomnia.
No,
no.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
No,
I have before.
It's awful.
Yeah,
that sucks.
That's not good.
But I don't,
I don't have it.
No,
no,
no.
I,
I'm,
but once I lay down at night and I'm
tired
now what kind of Diet do you follow?
Do you have a specific,
you said no.
Gluten,
no dairy,
dairy.
And then a couple of years ago,
um,
I,
uh,
so I,
I did an IVF treatment to freeze my eggs
because I'm getting older and I drive
race cars and I can't,
you know,
do any of that stuff.
So I was like,
look,
I'm going for the insurance policy here.
So what are they,
how do they get those out of there?
Okay.
Does he really want to know?
Yeah.
It's a weird method.
Right?
All right.
So you have a ton of shots for like a
month,
a ton of shots,
ton of shots.
Every day you stick them in your stomach
and you have a ton of shots.
And so they dropped your estrogen down
to nothing.
And then they ramp it up and then it
multiplies the follicles.
The follicles are what grows the egg.
So you go in after a while and you start
getting ultrasounds to see how many
follicles are growing on each side.
So,
um,
anyway,
it was good for me.
Um,
but that many grows and they want them
each to get to like one by basically
almost an inch by an inch,
each of them.
And I mean I had like,
I mean this is a lot of information,
but you know,
20 to 30 on each side.
That's a shitload of real estate in my
body.
It got very 30
inches on each side of the each one.
Yeah.
Like,
well,
did people think you were pregnant?
Yeah.
You do.
You look like three,
ma.
I mean it was huge.
I was so uncomfortable feeling all them
eggs in there.
It's horrible.
This is bobby.
You're number seven.
This is Mike.
I'm pretty sure they're all girls.
Um,
but uh,
it's um,
so I did that and they,
you do this trigger drug thing and then
you know,
36 hours on the minute you go in and you
retrieve it.
And what they do is they,
you get wheeled in the room is super
like humid and warm.
They runkle and um,
so animal wild things in there.
So they put you in like they put you in
like ski boots,
like tills get you get you up and ready.
And then some chick was like,
right,
I'm going to give you a little,
little something.
Actually.
I'm like,
girl,
you don't have to tell me.
Just do it.
Like that was what I told her and I was
asleep.
And they go in and every they go in with
a needle and retrieve every one of them
one by one with a needle,
I think.
Yeah.
They go in and puncture in through the,
through it and retrieve them sucked out
of their 24 and 19,
19 where mature 19 potential.
How do you think you're going to make?
Have you thought about it?
No,
no.
They say you need 20 to guarantee one.
So pretty much guaranteed one.
Wow.
But this is an insurance policy.
It doesn't mean I can try a different
way if I wanted to,
but anyway.
So,
okay.
Back to the back to the point,
like we just got way off track here,
but this is part of the story as to why
I decided to change my diet and my
workout and why I ended up writing a
book,
um,
was because I,
I gained like four pounds.
Okay.
Um,
just people I know there's people were
like,
well,
who cares?
Four pounds on my frame,
five foot who I'm small little.
And you know,
for any girl out there,
you know,
your genes only fit when you're exactly
the size that you are and then you gain
a couple pounds and they don't anymore.
I was just uncomfortable.
It just wasn't,
I just gained some weight and not
anything really.
Well it was,
it was,
it was legit.
Like I just gained some weight because
of the hormones.
So it instantly also gave me some
sympathy for people out there with
whether it's dudes and testosterone or
women with pregnancy or you know,
um,
uh,
menopause or whatever it is that changes
their hormones.
And sometimes you just gain weight.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this is,
this is real.
This isn't just some excuse for getting
older and being lax about your diet or
your exercise,
it really happens.
And so anyways,
so I decided to eat Paleo for like a
week.
Really.
I was going to do it for a week and I
did it,
um,
and I never stopped.
So that was two years ago.
And then I also started doing two a day
workouts because I wanted to change it
up and sort of kick things up a notch.
But I also realized that I was out
taking my dogs for walks and I was like,
well,
if I'm walking them I might as well run
and do a workout too.
So,
you know,
instead of mile and a half of walking
around the property,
I would go for three.
Wow.
So when you,
you say you do two a days,
like how do you break it up?
Um,
they're usually a little shorter.
Like I would say somewhere between 20 to
40 minutes each.
And um,
uh,
one of them will be,
I do upper body,
lower body and an ab day and I just
rotate through those.
Really.
I just,
I keep rotating through those because
look,
if you do,
if I do it right,
I'm so sore,
I can't do upper body again for a few
days.
So I just rotate through those in a nice
supplement.
And if I have time,
I do interval.
I'm running,
we're all like sprint for 30 seconds,
walk for 30 seconds,
Sprint for 30 s and I'll do that for 20
minutes.
And do you have someone train you or do
you do everything yourself?
No,
I do everything myself.
I write,
I love writing workouts.
I think it's the artistic side of me.
I like the balance and the flow of like
creating something that has fluidity and
make sense and there's good transitions
through movements.
So,
um,
I mean I see your big rogue jim going
in,
so I,
uh,
I be happy to program for you if you
want me to,
but it's going to frost,
crossfit style workouts.
Well,
I do a lot.
Like I said,
I don't do crossfit,
but most of the stuff I do is kettle
bells.
Yeah.
Dead lifts.
Chin ups.
Yeah.
Too many.
I,
I got a what's called Waffles Golf
Golfer's elbow.
Tell me about it.
My right elbow is feeling so sore for
like three days.
Is it right on?
Yeah.
It's like right on the side.
It's like right here.
It just got to give a shout out to Kelly
start.
He hooked me up with this crazy protocol
for a healing up my tendonitis.
What is it?
Is it legal started?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's uh,
mostly,
do you know who he is?
He's a,
the guy wrote that book becoming a
supple leopard and he's a,
a real wizard when it comes to like
exercise physiology and understanding
the body and his book's amazing and all
that new and improved modalities and
yeah,
he's,
he gave me a bunch of different things
but also a tool to scrape the area which
is going to be proud of like a blade,
like a metal.
Okay.
I've had that done before.
Yeah.
And topical CBD oil,
which is really good.
Legal.
Yes.
CBD is illegal across the board.
Okay.
Non Non psychoactive.
But the FDA is trying to stop that.
Of course.
Follow the money.
Yeah.
Was creeps tiny.
It's a good explanation for just about
everything.
Yeah.
They're trying to put it in the same
classification as heroin.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
So stupid.
It's just 100% pharmaceutical drug
companies,
institutions of decision making.
Yup.
Well,
it's just creepy.
People with money that don't want to
lose money to cbd oil because it's so
much better for you and healthy and
natural and does the exact same page and
how much the drug companies would lose
if Lorne gain,
if they started selling it fucks.
It's just they want to monopolize it.
That's the problem.
They want to patents.
They want to be able to patent things.
You know?
That's,
but that's,
uh,
like were talking about before about the
things that are in the Amazon.
I mean,
it stayed,
there's,
there so many different plants that can
deal with so many different ailments
that people have.
But I,
Alaska,
yeah,
that's one of them.
Sure.
Have you done it?
I haven't,
but it's interesting.
Yeah.
Have you done any psychedelics?
No.
Never done drugs ever.
No drugs,
no pot ever?
Never.
Oh,
you scared?
No,
I just,
my dad's scared the living daylights out
of me when I was a kid and he told me
that if I ever,
he's like,
you get tested for drugs and you fail,
you,
you won't ever be a race car driver.
You told me that about drinking and
driving too.
If you get,
if you lose your license,
you won't be able to race.
And then,
you know,
what are you going to be when you grow
up then?
You know,
he threatened me with,
Oh dad,
it's remedial remedial jobs and um,
yeah.
So He'd scared the living daylights out
of me.
Truth be told you can lose your license.
Still raise.
Also,
truth be told,
I didn't get drug tested until way
later,
but we do get drug tests.
You're running a drug farm.
Oh,
well one you're wanting to drug farm.
Well,
kind of I guess a drug farm lady.
It's legal buck 20 a hundred percent
drug farm.
It's wonderful,
delicious taste in drugs.
It sure is fucked up on wine.
Yeah.
And what does that,
that's true.
And addicted to drinking alcoholism.
I mean there's a lot of other things
that you can do that
altering,
that aren't addictive,
right?
You're running a plant based drug farm.
100% cash crops.
Yeah.
So you're doing,
you're a drug dealer.
Well,
let's just go all the way.
if I was going to do something,
what would be the first thing I would
do?
Pot.
Oh,
for sure.
Okay.
Nice and light.
Real slow.
Don't take much.
How quick does that mean?
It just take a little bit.
You don't want to freak out.
The one of the major problems that
people have when they first start
smoking pot,
they'll take like two or three heads and
he can take one when one like that's it.
Put it down,
right Jamie?
Yeah.
Jamie will tell you,
okay,
we'll hit walkaway.
Yeah,
don't fuck with edibles.
Leave those alone.
Those,
those,
you need to build up to those things.
So those are,
those are completely different
experience.
Experienced users.
While it's not just that even
experienced users,
they don't recognize the fact that it's
a completely different psychoactive
ingredient.
Yeah,
yeah.
When thc,
thc,
no,
when it's processed by your liver
produces 11 hydroxy metabolite,
which is four to five times more
psychoactive than thc.
It's way more potent.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Which is why people for reek out when
they eat edibles and they just don't,
don't eat the whole Brownie.
No.
Just a couple crumbs and then don't even
think about having any more for at least
two hours and let it settle in.
Let it,
yeah,
give yourself time.
Don't freak out for 15,
20 minutes and be like,
it's not working.
Right.
Don't do that.
Sometimes when I'm drinking I'm like,
I'm sure man,
this is my third drank.
It just doesn't seem to be working.
And then I hit it harder and then,
um,
I don't remember anything.
Brownout or blackout or drugs or do
drugs.
Yeah.
Actually one of the,
one of the first times I heard one of
your podcasts,
I think it was,
it was about dmt.
Yeah.
That's the motherlode DMT is the
psychoactive ingredient that's in Io
Osca and it's the most potent side.
That seems like a cleaner,
cleaner way to do it as opposed to
Iowasca where you throw up and shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's definitely probably,
uh,
it's also quicker,
you know,
like the worst,
the longest it's going to take a sec,
15 or 20 minutes,
but there are some places that are doing
it now where they're doing an
intravenously.
So those trips are apparently,
that was how they did it.
And,
um,
there's a book called DMT,
the spirit molecule molecule by this
guy,
Doctor Rick Strassman,
who did all these studies out of the
University of New Mexico.
And,
uh,
they were the first,
FDA approved clinical studies,
but it was a group of people.
Yeah,
he did it awesome.
Then about that.
It's amazing.
It was amazing,
but they didn't intervene intravenously.
Yeah.
And they were gone.
So for like 40 minutes,
like pull them off into the office to
the other dimension.
I was going to say,
so other dimension,
right?
This dream state,
is it,
what do you think is like a dream state?
Uh,
it's very similar because they believe
that your brain during heavy rem sleep
also produces dmt.
May think that's cause we all have it.
We all had the empty,
everybody has it.
Yeah.
Everybody has recurring and everyone.
Yes.
It's produced by your liver,
your lungs,
and now they know it's also produced at
least in rats by your pineal gland,
which is literally your third eye.
It's actually in certain reptiles.
It actually has a retina and the lens
it's,
yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
It is an eye.
I'm always trying to decalcify my
opinion.
Will Glenn,
is that real?
I don't know.
You get that from them crystal people in
Sedona?
Yeah.
They say it's like fluoride.
Fluoride is calcifying your pineal gland
man.
Like,
okay,
watch a cool thing like getting in
there.
Yeah.
How's it getting through my mouth and I
said,
are you sure?
Are you sure Florence?
Because nothing you are what you eat.
Sordo but are you what you drink?
You wine?
Yes.
I get better with age de.
Yeah.
I don't know if you've really,
your pineal gland actually gets
calcified by fluoride in drinking water.
I didn't.
That sounds like some hippie horseshit.
It does sound hippie horse shit.
I'd like to see some scientific proof,
but hey man,
with all the hippy shit,
there's not a lot of scientific proof
with it.
No,
no,
there's not a sense of knowing.
That's what it comes down to is a sense
of knowing like,
do you really feel like this is making
sense to you?
Does it register?
And you're like,
I don't know why I believe this,
but I just do.
I don't even know where it came from.
Yeah.
I don't know about that.
I'd rather trust scientists.
I like science too.
My sister and I went and saw Neil
degrasse Tyson and Indianapolis over the
winter when it was called the radio
thing.
It was called the,
uh,
an astrophysicist reads the newspaper.
Oh yeah.
So he like pulled Cray,
you know,
articles and you know,
just laughed about them basically.
That's cool.
Pluto came up because he was part of the
people part of the group that sort of
said the Pluto wasn't planet.
Yes.
Yeah.
People get very upset with him.
He also loved to point out how there'd
be something crazy and he'd be like,
let me point out,
this is in the science section of the
newspaper.
Like as if like how did this make it to
the science section?
Right?
He's going to come on here sometime in
February and they're going to,
he's going to talk to a guy who believes
the earth is flat.
Oh,
that guy,
he made fun of that guy too.
He's like,
let me show you are a reflection of what
it looks like if the earth was flat,
you know?
Of course it's,
you know,
shadow of a flat line.
It's like,
of course that's not true.
Well of course it's not true,
but there's a lot of young people out
there today that believe the earth is
flat.
Do you believe the earth is flat?
This is,
most certainly do not,
but I think it's,
I mean,
do they,
do they not think we actually go into
outer space and they think that that's
fake too,
but I think it's just a matter of,
I think we landed on the moon.
If there's anything that I think is one
of the more attractive conspiracy
theories,
it's the moon landing was because the
only time they did it was between 1969
in 1972 they did seven missions,
six were successful and that's the only
time in human history that people have
been more than I think 400 miles above
the earth's surface.
Everything else,
all the space shuttle missions,
all of the space station missions,
all that stuff is inside of 400 miles.
The moon is like 260,000 miles there and
back and they've never even sent a
chicken in the space and had it come
back alive.
They never sent anything in this space
other than people like into deep space
passed the van,
Allen Radiation Belt packs,
the MAG needles fear.
I think most likely we went,
but if there's ever a conspiracy theory
that's attractive to me it's that one
cause I just think it would be
fascinating if during the Nixon
administration they really did fake it
and there's,
there's a lot of weirdness to it.
They fake it.
Well,
first of all to show military
superiority to the Russians.
And again,
I'm not saying,
and I used to believe they did fake it.
I was,
I was heavily on the side that they
faked it,
but then I realized,
I don't know Jack Shit about
astrophysics.
I don't know Jack Shit about rocket
travel.
I don't,
I mean I'm just talking out of my ass.
So like me saying that they didn't go
was literally an ignorant perspective.
Like well it's just being attracted to
conspiracy theories,
which is fun.
That's the problem is that conspiracy
theories are really fun.
Like big foot.
It's really fun.
You have photos are really fun.
All that stuff
of stuff to get to the get to the core
because there's,
there's,
there's arguments on both sides.
There is,
but it's also you have to recognize in
yourself that you do not want the
official story to be true.
And I do not an almost every single
thing that happens like,
you know,
Moon landing or do Ufo landings.
Right.
Any crazy shit.
I want the crazy shit to be real.
I always want the UFO thing to be a real
thing.
They do have it.
It's believe in aliens.
Yes.
I think it's more than likely that
there's something else.
I feel like that we're the only thing in
the universe.
This is a little ridiculous.
It seems stupid.
It seems pretty ignorant and arrogant.
Yeah,
but I don't think that it's what we
think it is.
I think it's a most likely far beyond
the,
the places that we can currently travel
too,
and I think that by the time they get to
a high level of sophistication,
they're most likely not even organic
anymore.
And I think that that's the future of
the human race.
I thought most of consciousness,
well,
I think maybe that,
but I also think there's a real problem
with the possibility of artificial
intelligence.
I think human beings are about to create
life.
Whether we recognize it as life or not,
what artificial life is going to be his
life.
Artificial intelligence is going to have
the ability to change itself,
multiply what human beings have been
able to do in terms of technological
innovation by a rate of something
insane.
Like in two years they'll be able to do
10,000 years of innovation in terms of
like what we're capable of doing.
So I think that what we're looking at
now is the,
the last days of biological life.
I think a hundred years from now,
500 years from now,
whatever it is,
there won't be biological humans
anymore.
I think they'll,
this'll be an archaic out
dainty will change as we know it.
Yeah.
And I can,
I mean,
you know,
I don't believe in everything the Bible
says,
but you know,
was that in the Bible?
Well,
so the apocalypse and one of the changes
as we know it,
I think the apocalypse slope world will
end as we know it,
right?
But I think the apocalypse,
like the stuff in the Bible,
that's all local.
Like if you,
if you lived where Hurricane Katrina
hit,
you would think the apocalypse was
there,
right?
If you were in,
you know,
anywhere where something really fucking
crazy happened and you didn't have any
contact with the outside world.
No cell phones,
no radio,
no TV didn't exist.
Sure.
True.
You would isolate it.
Yeah.
I think that's what all of our,
our notions of the apocalypse are there
periodic natural disasters that are
unbelievably devastating.
Like they've proven that the entire
human race was,
was down to a few thousand people
because of a supervolcano around 70,000
years ago.
So I think there's been a series of
those events throughout history where
the human race is brought down to an,
uh,
an almost unmanageable level and then we
repopulate it.
Huh.
And I think that that's probably the
origins of the apocalypse or asteroidal
impacts,
which are very common.
They've happened all throughout history.
Ai is going to just eliminate biological
humans.
I think it's entirely possible that
we're going to give into it too.
Then we're going to take it,
we're going to first of all become
symbiotic.
We're going to take something and put it
inside of us.
It's going to enhance us was it's our
ability to communicate,
whether it's our ability to see,
we're going to start implanting chips
into ourselves and then they're going to
have improved body parts.
Like say if you break your arm and
they're like,
look Danica,
we can fix your arm,
but it's going to take a year.
You have,
you know,
17 broken bones or we can replace it
with an arm that works better and it'll
feel just like a regular arm.
And I'm going to bring in Mike and Mike
has a fake arm and he's going to show
you how it works and Mike's going to
come in.
I'm so much happier with my arm.
Then I was in my face,
come up with my real arm,
then a new drug drug pushers.
They're like,
no,
this lookout works and I'll,
it's a free vacation to um,
if you do this,
uh,
I,
I've watched some,
I heard some youtube video of like,
it was someone who channels other,
oh,
one of those hours,
I think it was channeling the Palladian
so,
oh yeah.
For probably totally legit.
Yeah.
And she talked about how it was talking
about how as a,
as a human race,
we have to be careful.
We don't alter ourselves too much
because then we won't exist as a human
race because we won't be able to
procreate.
And that is what keeps our race alive.
That's probably true.
I mean,
if you think about where we're going to
go,
but also doesn't it have to
keep evolving?
I mean,
if we've got back,
look,
do you think like monkeys when they were
living in trees thrown shitty
each other or different than that?
Now we gotta be chill.
Otherwise we're going to stop being
monkeys who won't be able to throw shit
at each other and Dodge Jaguars,
bananas all day.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think people are afraid of change and
I think the human race is afraid of
change too.
But we're by no means perfect.
Most people don't do things right.
They're all,
everyone's afraid of change,
right?
Taking a chance,
Having it be different.
Maybe it's worse.
Well,
Dick,
maybe it's better.
You know?
Well,
that's like the hallmark of your whole
life.
Look at your 100% I'm,
I'm not afraid of change.
I'm not.
Okay,
so you have to roll it arm.
I have a moment.
I'll take the arm.
I'll,
I have a moment of,
um,
uh,
you know,
it was fear of like,
Oh shit.
And then there's the next moment is,
well,
maybe it's better than I could ever
expect.
What if they were imagined?
They'll give you two options.
They give you one robot arm that you
never have to work out.
It will always be strong.
You can get that one or you can get one
that you constantly have to work out.
Oh,
I would,
I'd probably take the robot.
But which,
which robot arm would you take?
The one that you constantly have to work
out.
What would you take the one that's just
perfect?
Yeah,
I'd probably take the perfect one.
Never have to exercise.
Just Bam.
Just jacked all the time.
If I wanted a,
I mean,
working out,
if I still needed to do that for like
the,
you know,
feel good endorphin hormone sort of,
state,
then I would still do that right here by
your brain,
just,
well,
yeah.
And I would go do a lot more stuff like
walking around in nature.
Hmm.
That's good answer because that's,
I mean,
I really find enjoyment out of that.
I mean to find enjoyment out of the
intensity level of things and the
confidence that I get or the,
you know,
being able to shift my mindset to this
sort of like all go all in,
not no pain,
no gain.
That's so cheesy,
but like I can endure and the confidence
that comes from enduring and pushing
through.
I enjoy that.
I enjoy that development of my mind and
my discipline and my confidence.
I do.
Um,
but I'm probably just shifting more into
enjoying,
you know,
things that are a little more peaceful
too.
So shifting more and to enjoy nature.
Yeah.
But that would be the most fucked up
thing.
It's like you didn't enjoy nature
anymore.
They started replacing body parts and
they're like,
you didn't give a shit about the forest.
Oh,
that would be sad.
I'll be sad.
I wouldn't take that body part then
probably wouldn't know until it's too
late.
Until they replaced probably going to be
dead before all this is real.
So that's what I think
those aliens are.
When people see Aliens,
those gray aliens,
Gray.
See guys,
I think that's just what we're going to
become.
That's what I think.
I've been thinking that a lot.
I think it's natural.
If you look at what a monkey is,
and then if we were at some point in
time,
like some ancient hominid like
Australia,
pithy gas or whatever,
Cro Magnon man,
and then we moved on to become homo
sapiens,
the f.
If we keep going in that direction,
this is what we're going to look like.
We're gonna look like a little skinny
things.
A big heads
lollipops.
Yeah.
That's what I looked like when I had my
helmet on and I'm in my race suit.
People are like alien.
That's a good point,
right?
Because I have a regular helmet.
That's right.
Yeah.
I didn't even think of that.
Could your helmet is like,
that would be like a big guy wearing an
enormous helmet.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Do you have a strong neck?
Most must have a wicked now.
Can I do,
do you do exercises with it?
I don't need to.
You don't just carry on the helmet
around all the time.
It's probably that and just looking up,
looking up to my nine foot target for
wall balls and like,
oh my neck hurts.
Yeah.
Nah,
just,
you know,
you're not out of the car,
out of the car that long.
It might hurt a little bit when I get
back in an indy car again because the g
forces are higher.
But you also lean your head against the
headrest.
Usually the only thing that would make
me hurt my,
make my neck hurt a little bit as road
courses at the beginning of the road of
indycar season.
What does it line to test?
Because acceleration and deceleration,
there's nothing to hold you from like
your neck going,
your head going forward.
I mean there is,
but not to the level that you would
drive that way.
Um,
there's just a device that is in case
you're in an accident,
but it still moves.
So you know,
holding,
holding your neck forward and backwards
is a lot more sore than side to side
just because you have a head rest so we
can use it.
Yeah.
Get out of a long race.
Is your whole body tired?
Yeah.
I mean in stock cars it's,
so,
it's really a lot about dehydration.
Dehydration.
Yeah.
I'm in the car.
It's like 130,
140 degrees in there now.
Do you have a tube or you started to,
I wonder from a to camelback that goes
through the front of my helmet,
a couple of blowers,
the back blower,
a helmet blower,
things that are cooler air,
but I'm here to tell you it's still hard
to sell on there or did I imagine?
Yeah.
I mean there's a fire in a gigantic iron
block
in front of you.
Yeah.
When the water and oil temperature is
300 degrees.
Yeah.
Jesus,
it sort of,
it's like a greenhouse in the car.
It's right.
It runs right underneath you to do.
You think you're going to miss it?
That's a great question.
I was talking about this just the other
day,
like,
am I going to miss the intensity?
Am I going to miss certain?
I mean,
I don't know if I'll,
I think I will miss some of it a little
bit.
Every now and again I'm driving down the
road and I'm like,
oh,
I'll probably miss it a little bit.
But um,
but uh,
yeah,
again,
I'm a decisive person,
so I'm good.
I'm sure you're good.
I'm just wondering more if I'm going to
miss the,
the intensity level of the job and the
highs being so high,
but the lows being low,
I mean,
that's the,
that's how you get the highest right and
the duality of the,
of the environment.
Um,
I'm wondering if I'll miss some of that
and if whatever I do on the side will be
enough.
What is the age that most people retire
from racing?
I'm 35 I'm a slightly young,
I would say early forties.
After a while they just,
their body just takes too much and
you're just exhausted.
I mean honestly,
like,
especially if it's Nascar,
he was just exhausted.
I mean it's,
I mean that's my feeling anyway.
You know,
you're gone for 40 weeks,
a year on the road and these,
you know,
really luxurious places of the world on
the barbecue world tour,
like grilling out of your bus and living
out of a bus for most of your life and
you know,
on the road in and out of airplanes,
hours of nothing to do on the weekends
while you're,
you know,
sitting there.
So just kind of the grind.
So I think he kind of just get a little
worn out.
I could only imagine,
you know,
I mean even like you were talking about
interviews and stuff like yeah,
I enjoy doing interviews that aren't
based around how's your car this
weekend?
You know what I mean?
There's just so boring.
They really weren't.
So it's fun for me to talk about working
out or cooking or wine,
food,
you know,
all that stuff.
It's just interesting.
Or aliens.
I can only imagine the boring grind of
the media tour that you must have to go
through when you're racing all the time.
Do you what Diana?
Good.
You are moving quite fast out there
today.
You have over performer.
I was watching the uh,
the uh,
the old south park episode.
They had a bunch of Nascar drivers on
South Park and you know,
it was the,
it was when um,
cartman's trying to be poor and stupid
so he could race in Nascar and he was
sponsored by badges cell and he
ate a ton of ad is still to make them as
stupid as he could and you realize that
the more stupid he got,
the more money spent in more in daddy
got.
And that's how you got poor.
They're just bought like jet skis and
I think he says at one point in time,
Danica,
you're not having both halves porn
stupid as I am.
Oh that's right.
You were in it.
Yeah,
I was in it.
Did you use your own?
No.
Nice.
Somebody else does all their own stuff.
I was on the simpsons that year too,
and I did my voiceover for that.
But for,
for South Park now.
Did you love it?
I was awesome.
I mean,
I don't care what they say.
If you're on a show,
it's flattering.
Right.
They to make,
to make tv in a different capacity means
you're being noticed.
Well,
especially South Park.
Yeah.
I think that's the funniest show that's
ever existed.
Yeah.
Especially like all time.
If you look at the,
uh,
all the episodes they've done,
I mean,
it doesn't even make sense how creative
they are.
That's what I was thinking is how
they're just insightful ahead of things
a lot and definitely clever.
Like with there,
the delivery of it.
Yeah.
They're wizards.
Completely bizarre.
What kind of car do you drive in regular
life?
Please don't say like a Prius.
No.
Throw it.
Like if you're like,
oh,
I just drive.
The other day I was throwing some things
into the recycling bin and I'm like,
I'm just trying to do my part because
let's face it,
I burned fuel for a living.
Yeah.
Right.
In terms of how much fossil fuel,
I wonder if you could see a chart,
how much fossil fuel the average person
burns.
I would not be doing well on that.
That would not be a,
I would not do well with the
tree huggers are vegans of the world.
All the people loving animals like me,
I'm all those people.
I love the forest.
I try and eat vegetables most of the
time,
things like that.
But yeah,
I also don't do my part when it comes to
my job.
What kind of car do you drive?
Uh,
so I've had cars for years through um,
through the manufacturer.
So,
um,
this past year we were sponsored by
Ford.
So I had,
I had a ford expedition,
e l I didn't know what each element it
means extra long.
Oh,
I had extra space in the back.
Yeah,
it was,
yeah,
they hook you up with a Mustang,
shelby.
Well,
that's not very practical.
Three fifties.
We weren't even allowed to customize
the,
customize the wheels on that thing.
So yeah,
it was bare,
bare bones because they,
that was part of the contract.
What you're alive.
You get a car but you can't get anything
dressed up.
So
I could have had a raptor I guess,
but like trucks aren't really me.
Whatever better than the l
a yeah.
So,
and then I had a Tahoe and I drove for
Chevy before that.
I would think that you would want
something fast.
Um,
so that I a,
I bought my first car and that's the
last car I bought.
Oh yeah.
A long time ago I bought a Mercedes ml
63 amg.
It was like a suv,
souped up suv.
That was a long time ago.
I was like 10 years ago.
Um,
I uh,
I bought a range rover.
So since then you've just been using
manufacturer cars from the sponsors
because they're free dollars and they're
not,
you know,
whatever is free is free.
Is that like a part of the contract?
Like this the only car you're allowed to
drive?
Um,
probably not,
but,
but that was the only car you drove to
the race track?
Probably the one driving your,
yeah,
company car.
Yeah.
I'll probably good move.
But other drivers have other cars too.
But do you think that once you retire
you will start,
let go and god down,
whatever need to get something from
cargill?
What?
Nope,
not a cargo.
I'm sorry to disappoint you mean how'd
you,
how'd you even say those words?
I know carb.
Do you know who you are?
And I'm not going to Patrick.
I know.
Race car driver,
woman.
I don't even know how many cylinders are
in things.
I'm just,
I just drive him.
I'm just good at that.
You don't know how many cylinders?
I don't know.
I think we have eight.
That's so crazy.
I just lost the sound.
Too many fans.
How could he be such a good driver and
not know anything about cars?
I don't need to.
That's a good way of looking at it.
I don't build it straight and have to go
to school for engineering.
I remember the beginning of our top 10
years old,
10 years old.
I remember.
So,
uh,
yeah.
I just,
I can drive them.
You need to get yourself on those new
shelby gt.
500 700 horsepower.
I see.
Oh,
I shelby.
okay.
Not the GT.
Not The gt 500 or the PT cruiser to
shelby just put out a new math problem
with those four gts.
They're awesome.
But the paddle shifts,
you want a manual,
you want to stick?
Yeah.
Alex sticks.
It's more fun.
It is.
Yeah.
Just some racy.
It's just more fun.
And I have a Bronco,
a 1977 bronco.
It's not down there driving that is,
you know,
to stick.
It's like,
it's not that fast,
but it's just,
it just feeds your testosterone,
mechanical,
mechanical.
They feel it's analog.
You know,
my car would be good off the line.
I bought a Lamborghini along while back
and uh,
it didn't have a cup holder,
so I was like,
well this is stupid.
This is not practical.
So yeah.
So then I bought the Mercedes
and that had a cup holder.
I had a couple of cup holders.
Yep.
So it was good,
but then it,
you know,
technology evolved and it didn't have
Bluetooth to play my music.
So I was like,
well,
I'm not going to have to get rid of
this.
And that was when I started driving for
a chevy.
And then I got a Tahoe and I liked that.
And then I got a [inaudible].
They didn't give you a corvette?
I didn't ask for one.
How could you not want one driving
force?
Certain practical car.
If I wanted a corvette,
I could buy one.
Oh,
okay.
I know you're good.
But I would say be like,
come on,
hook it up.
I'm not,
yeah,
I,
I'm not a car girl.
We went over this.
Understand this though.
I keep,
I keep wanting to catch you in that lie.
No,
I,
I don't care.
I just,
I have cars or like purses for me.
I just need one nice one and when it
wears out I'll get a new one.
You don't like purses?
Not really.
Really cared girl.
Just needed one.
That looks good.
And
what about shoes?
I like shoes.
I have a lot of shoes.
Yeah,
a girl.
I'm definitely a girl,
but not purses.
A curl
my own hair today.
Wow,
that's crazy.
How do you do makeup?
Yeah.
Okay.
My shoulder hurts.
Hairspray.
What does this stuff now I'm very much a
girl.
I believe you.
That's what if people ask me what it,
what is it about you that people would
be surprised?
And I'm telling them like much more
girly away from the track than you'd
think because I'm really aggressive at
the track and I don't look very happy
and away from the track I'm,
I try and be funny and I smile more and
I'm much more relaxed.
Are you surprised that with all your
success,
success and all the attention that
you've gotten from your success as the
only woman on your level in,
in professional racing,
are you surprised that more women aren't
entering in,
that you haven't sort of opened the door
or do you think that it's such a
specialized and unique thing to do that
it's just not something that a lot of
women gravitate towards?
I used to say that for a hundred men
that came through,
if you found a good,
he takes a hundred to find a good one
that comes pretty quickly.
But to go through a hundred women takes
a lot longer because there are so few of
them.
Um,
there are more coming through,
but I just think that,
you know,
over time it just takes a lot longer to
find good ones.
But I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm,
I think back to a,
this is my ego talking.
I think back to,
um,
a long time ago,
when,
um,
Paul Newman was still alive and we were
on a late night show together,
probably Letterman,
and he was asked before I went on,
he was the first guest if there was
going to be another driver,
another girl that comes through that
compares to me and he said he didn't
think so.
Maybe there won't be,
maybe there will be no shit.
Yeah,
he knew his shit.
Maybe.
I mean,
you're unique.
I'm sure there will be someday.
I meet a lot of women like you because
of mma.
Oh,
there's those savages that enter into
mma.
The women that fall wind up fighting in
MMA.
There's a lot of them.
And I'm kind of stunned at how many of
them there are.
But I,
when I say they're like you,
I mean they're bold,
powerful,
unique people that are,
does take wild chances.
I mean the type of person that is like a
holly home or someone like that.
I think the big difference lies and
there are a lot of people that are
strong,
aggressive,
confident,
you know,
assertive,
bold,
but to then be able to keep it together
and um,
up,
up above their shoulders.
That's another,
that's the difference.
Keep it together in the pressure of a
race.
Yeah.
And the pressure of whatever moment is
have that you're having whatever
pressures are being put on you around an
event or for one.
I mean those are,
that's really hard.
The right people around you being able
to filter the shit and let him like keep
the good,
um,
s keep your own confidence up.
Um,
that's,
that's hard.
That's the hardest part.
And then being able to flip that switch
when you're performing to,
of course then not have doubts,
but um,
more confidence.
I think everything that you've said
would be mirrored by what a woman who
competes at the very highest levels of
MMA would say.
I think they would find all those things
to be factors.
You know,
it's just,
I'm,
I'm really stunned that you literally
are the only one.
I mean there's,
that's a,
that's a incredibly rare position.
Do you ever stop and think about like
what if you weren't there?
It's not like it's forbidden for women.
Huh?
I never thought about it like that.
I've moans mostly only thought about it
from the perspective of like,
have I thought about what I've done in
the sport because it's stuff that people
haven't done before.
And usually my answer is,
is that someday we'll look back and,
you know,
be able to have a little bit more
perspective on it.
But right now I'm just kind of in the
middle of it.
MMM.
But yeah,
I've never thought about it like that.
Like what if I was never there?
Yeah.
I mean,
you're the only one.
So if you were never there,
what it would,
it would just be constantly a boys' club
forever.
I mean,
I,
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm really fascinated by complete
outliers.
I mean,
you're,
you're a complete outlier in that
regard.
I mean,
there's not like 30 girls,
oh,
there's 500 men,
but there's 30 girls.
Know How many men are Nascar drivers?
Uh,
well the field is 40.
Yeah.
So 40 men,
one check.
That's crazy.
And then there's a bunch of people that
are trying to do it.
Are there any women that are trying,
again,
a lower formula is other,
some that do some part time stuff.
And I'm trying to think of someone has
done like a full season.
I don't know,
back in indy car there was some girls
who did more.
There were like at one,
one indy 500,
there was like five of us.
But most of the time there's none
or one,
um,
comes in waves.
Do you stop?
I mean,
do you think that when you stop and you
look back on your career,
you'll take into account and maybe have
a more objective sense of what an impact
that you've had?
Sure,
yeah,
of course.
But I need distance right from it.
I need to gain perspective that way.
Does that make sense?
It does.
Yeah.
I'm sure in your career too,
like I mean to be able to identify the
things that you've done,
the influence you've had over people
with the conversations you've had with
the,
with the things in business you've done.
I mean,
it's hard to see when you're in the
middle of it.
Yeah.
I don't look at that.
You don't want to look at that?
No,
no.
Cause I don't want to get distracted.
Yeah.
That's why people don't in the mall.
Cause it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
But I'm,
when I'm doing a lot of people are doing
what you're doing is very,
uh,
it's just tag it to be a woman that does
the thing that many men think is
probably one of the most manly things
you could do other than fighting and
maybe football.
Yeah.
It's like race,
car driver.
Like a little boy.
What do you want
to be when you grow up?
Billy army or a race car driver.
But that's just lightening McQueen.
I mean,
yeah.
I mean it's like a natural thing for men
to gravitate.
Yeah.
Towards it.
Dad always said he was just like,
Gosh,
I had cursed with three girls in the
house,
goes my mom and then me and my sister
and I'm like,
Hm Dad,
what more did you want?
Like what more did you want with it?
If you had a boy as a son,
like what was he going to do that's
right.
Cooler than what I'm doing.
He'd be out there banging chicks.
That's what he's missing.
You think my dad would think that was
cool
if his son was banging chicks?
I would think probably that's my boy.
Scared shitless for me.
Yeah,
that's gotta be,
I think still in my adult life.
It's like er,
wealthy.
They had the courage to let you go to
England by herself when you were 16 I
mean that and race over there on another
continent all the way across an ocean
sort of.
You did get hurt to get to you.
We'll take forever.
Yeah.
Bold.
What is the worst crash you've ever been
in?
A my first crash in indy cars.
My very first race.
Whoa.
Kind of paralleled getting an a go kart
for the first time.
Having a big crash,
but yeah,
it was,
um,
homestead,
Miami and uh,
there was a big accident and I was
running low and someone was sliding down
the track that had damage and they
clipped my right rear and shot me up
into the wall head first and um,
slid down the track.
And I don't remember that part.
I don't remember getting out.
I don't remember walking to the
ambulance,
but there's footage of all of it.
And I walked the wrong way away from the
ambulance.
I was walking the opposite direction and
then I was kind of like stumbling
around.
And then I got back to the back to the,
um,
uh,
medical truck and then I got in and
apparently I was very repetitive on the
way to the hospital and I kept asking
them,
did it look bad?
And they were like,
you have asked us that a few times and
I'm like,
oh,
I'll just stop.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That's a severe concussion.
That's one of the things that happens is
the people ask the same questions over
and over again.
Hmm.
Well then I've had one,
let's hope I don't have a cte.
I'm sure you probably do.
I probably do a little bit.
Yeah,
just a little bit.
The devil touch Oh,
matter makes you more risky.
Does it does,
yeah.
That's crazy.
That sort of thing.
One of the things it does,
it makes people more impulsive.
Do UFC people get,
yeah,
100%.
Did you see that video?
Is there,
are they doing studies in UFC like they
did in the nfl with,
I'm doing tests after they've passed
away to know if like they had cte.
Isn't that what nfl had they,
I got,
there was a study that came out last
year.
It was like almost all but one out of a
hundred and some had cte.
Yeah,
it was,
um,
I forget the numbers,
but yeah,
there was only like one or two people
that didn't have it.
Right.
Yeah.
No,
a hundred odd hasn't done that.
The UFC hasn't been around as long as
the NFL obviously.
So we,
um,
we're not dealing with the same data
pool,
but I'm sure when people
do pass away,
we're going to find it.
It's just varying levels.
I heard they actually have a test now
for cte.
Oh,
saffron,
the trauma surgeon that you're alive.
Yeah.
What would you do if you had it?
Making excuses.
I just go extra crazy.
Well that's why I'm gambling.
Naked
bottle of whiskey in each arm.
Chug,
pals.
So insightful.
This question,
did you see the video that just came out
from a couple of days ago from the guy
that hit the off ramp and went flying
through the air and landed in a house in
the second floor of a house?
His car's poking out the side,
but I couldn't,
he couldn't do it again if he had to.
I'm sure.
No,
no,
it's just total random.
Crazy luck.
But it is hilarious.
I mean,
and see if you,
once you find it then go to crystal Lee
instagram.
Cause Deleah had a hilarious meme that
he created,
but this car hit this hit like a
barrier.
Hit one of those cement barriers and
literally got launched into the air and
stuck into the second floor of a
building.
I don't know.
What country does it merit?
Marico Marico two people escaped.
The injuries are serious injuries.
How the fuck did,
I mean I wonder how they got out of the
car.
I mean it's,
it's the way it's hanging out of the
building.
Hopefully it's front wheel drive and
they could keep accelerating to get a
little further and so they can get out
of the car.
That's spoken like a true race cars,
right?
They get about it that way.
Yeah.
Here it is.
Here's the video footage so you could
see it and there's the car washes.
It hits the,
see this is that.
It's hard to tell there,
but they literally went across traffic.
They're speeding.
You can see it again.
The guy goes across traffic,
flies in the air.
Let's see.
Go to Christa.
[inaudible] page is instagram page and
find the meme cause then you can see
that and what you,
let's get this guys.
Oh that's crystal.
He is there.
He says,
come her.
Come over me.
I can't tonight.
Her,
my parents were on the first floor and
I'm on a second floor and I had been
coins me.
I mean,
that fucking car is stuck inside that
building.
I mean,
you wouldn't believe that that was real
if you didn't see it.
There
is that Nissan need,
that dentist office that he just parked
himself.
Yeah.
Here's the question.
What do you do if you're in the car?
Like it gets stuck there,
even climb out,
probably drunk.
You gotta be drunk,
right?
I mean,
there's nobody or something.
So you just,
you open the door and you wait.
You,
uh,
you take on the sprained ankle and you
jump and Jesus went and then it lands on
your fucking head.
The thing falls out of the building
right thing here.
You call the cops who are honest to,
okay,
is there a big coins?
And then you go,
oh my God,
that's funny.
Who put up the video?
What is the,
where's the video from some dude's name?
What is his name?
Kenny homes.
It's a k homes live.
He's the guy who fo it.
He's from NBC La,
I guess.
Minor injuries.
Hmm.
That's crazy.
Oh,
Santa Ana.
People are out of their fucking mine.
That's where Eddie bravos from Santa Ana
people.
Boom,
look at that car flying through the air.
It's just the fact that it's stuck into
the building that's just so ridiculous.
It's probably for a movie now.
When you drive in regular life,
are you a lead foot?
I'm a very aggressive driver.
I know it.
Yes I am.
I'm,
I have a large comfort zone.
I say people piss me off a lot.
They are horrible drivers and I,
um,
I'm,
I'm very,
uh,
yeah.
The only way I can make sure that I
don't get a speeding ticket is to not
drive.
How many speeding tickets have you
gotten?
Oh,
I've been pulled over at least 20 times.
I got pulled over three times in three
days at one point when I,
my Mustang Cobra,
my first ever car.
Oh,
Jesus.
You see?
That's why I'm surprised you don't have
a fast car.
Oh,
I always make sure it's a good car.
Like that fast car.
But I mean like today,
like right now,
like when you're driving around,
pulling up.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
your everyday life.
Yeah.
Well I'm driving rentals because I don't
live here.
I mean not,
I mean here,
I mean in real life.
Real life.
Oh yeah.
Like where's my sports car?
Yeah.
Well I,
you know,
in 40 weeks a year I'd do that.
So you just get people mover.
I got two dogs.
Right.
So you get enough of it.
All my bags,
I feel like I'm trying to sell you a
car.
What car should I buy?
I would say something Martin.
Something that you do like American made
cars?
Yeah,
I would say I tend to die.
I don't care if they are or aren't
really well,
I have a porsche.
I liked that.
I like a German cars too.
They're more reliable.
What I like about American cars is I
like the sound.
I liked the way that I just is a rumble
throatiness to it.
Do it.
You like to like,
so you like to make noise on the road?
I'm,
I'm a loud person.
Yeah.
I have a 65 corvette with straight
pipes.
Those still side pipes.
Yeah.
Super kind of know what that is.
I can picture it kind of race car
driver,
but it's a state that's what's
important.
I
don't care.
Nope.
But I would feel like we're someone like
you,
once you transitioned away from racing,
then it's going to be more important to
you because you're going to like miss
the capabilities of those things
at might be true.
Yeah,
that might be true.
I might have to,
uh,
oh,
there's my car.
Oh,
that was a good looking car and sweet
car.
Jay Leno of course.
Of course.
He loves cars.
Yeah.
I'm not an,
I also don't really like old cars,
so,
um,
that looks pretty good.
It's pretty fancy looking.
But um,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a new car person.
I like new modern sports cars.
I do as well.
But that car is a 65 on the outside,
but all the underpinnings are completely
modern.
It has a one supercharged engine,
so it does a modern corvette engine,
Scott,
modern brakes,
modern suspension.
You don't know what any of that stuff
means,
dude.
Nope.
That's cool.
I know that my very first car,
my Mustang Cobra,
I drove it so hard that I needed an
8,000 miles.
I was on my third set of brakes.
We put stiffer sway bars in it so that
it would handle better.
Um,
it was uh,
yeah,
I went through three,
so yeah,
it was on my third set of brakes and
8,000 miles.
And now you say Mustang Cobra.
Like what year was this?
Oh,
this is when I first,
this is my first ever car,
so I was 16.
So I think it was a um,
uh,
97.
It was,
yeah,
it was,
I'm not saying they're not cool,
but it was back when they were more cool
when you know they were a lot,
lot less common.
Okay.
Yeah,
they were okay back on the back end of
the Cobra cool days.
Yeah.
No,
the 90 sevens were okay there.
All right.
Like it run the eighties is when uh,
they came out with the 5.0 and then,
then like mustangs had a little bit more
power again.
So what's your dream car then?
That corvette.
That's my favorite car.
Oh,
now what?
Then?
No,
try that around.
Do you drive it much?
All the time.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
it doesn't really rain in California,
so I guess you can,
well it has a top.
You put the driving rains.
I have.
Oh,
good for you.
Good for you.
It's just a car.
Yeah.
Oh me,
I'm not afraid of it getting wet.
The only problem is it's slippery,
you know,
it doesn't have any control or any of
that.
It's just all engine power and Torque
and yeah,
that's fun.
Yeah.
I remember driving a Camaro around in
the rain and it was handled like trap.
Just get one of the new ones.
Camaro.
Zl One,
they have a new one,
650 horsepower.
It's fucking ridiculous.
I mean,
nobody even barely uses the full speed
of that here.
I don't know.
What am I?
Oh,
so I was actually going to tell you
about this.
This is,
I did a,
a road and track,
um,
cover article where I test drove,
it was a porsche,
a corvette.
Um,
Eh,
I think it was a viper of some sort,
a viper.
And then there was,
um,
a,
a Lamborghini Mercia logo and I'll,
I mean,
my experience was the,
the Porsche was loose,
which is this one.
The corvette was tight,
which meant it was the most comfortable
and stable to drive.
Um,
the,
uh,
I think it was a viper.
The Viper was just light on its feet,
Kinda just didn't really,
it wasn't very stuck and it was just
kind of clunky.
It's about seven or eight years old,
is that right?
Oh,
at least.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
the,
the Lamborghini was,
was also light.
I mean it just went so fast,
but it's pretty well balanced,
but probably a little on the loose side.
So,
you know,
they stopped making vipers.
But I know the car for you does it car
that's for sale right now that,
uh,
I saw this morning.
No,
no,
no.
I'm trying to sell you a car.
This whole,
no,
uh,
Giappo link had a rare,
one of the,
this one dealership in 2017.
The country bought up like 90% of the
vipers and they ordered them in a bunch
of crazy paints games.
And they ordered this hot pink viper.
Shut up.
Yeah.
Me To drive a car.
You got to see it.
I drive it.
It's so fucking bad ass.
I'd drive it.
I like that.
Cool.
Or if a due to drive a pink car and I
would drive like some like stainless
steel,
silver,
you know,
I would drive it and then I'd get a
rainbow license plate.
So people would just assume I'm gay.
There's no way around it.
I've got a rainbow plate.
You've got a pink car.
Just let it out sound it.
Isn't that it's shit.
It was a,
I'm by google news feed this morning.
I looked at that.
I was like,
if I was a church that,
that'd be my fucking car.
But it's like crazy metallic hot pink
Viper Mary Kay car.
No,
that's not it.
That's old.
That shit's old red.
Yeah,
that's red.
It's a 2017.
It might not even be joppa link.
I might,
uh,
that,
that would think that was what I was
reading to drive it.
Okay.
You don't have to pull it up.
That's good thought,
but rather have black.
Let me guess.
Black.
Uh,
black tinted windows,
black,
black wheels,
black whoa.
Darkness.
Like a darth vader type thing.
So bad ass.
More.
More masculine than feminine.
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure out what kind of,
oh,
there it is.
That's not it.
But that's an old one too,
but it's all right.
No worries.
Those crows,
someone looks gross.
The other one didn't look so gross.
It's more of a darker pink.
You don't have to find a chamber.
Forget it.
She's easy.
She's going to hate it no matter what.
She wants Darth Vader,
pink corvettes that,
uh,
Angela Andrew,
I saw her the other day.
I saw her driving that.
Do know who Angelina's Angelina is a
woman who when I moved to California in
the 90s,
she used to have these billboards all
around California.
Of what?
It's her.
Oh,
her like in her bikini.
Uh,
like she would just say her.
It would just say her name and her phone
number and that's,
that's,
he knows those billboards.
Oh,
shoot.
Well,
yeah,
that's her.
And so these,
and I'd be like,
what the fuck is Angelina?
And everybody would be like,
aw,
she's like this local celebrity.
And so she apparently is just a wealthy
lady who,
uh,
all of her time here has done that.
Just got these big billboards.
Yeah.
She's doing a split on top of a
corvette.
Is that a good thing?
Um,
for her,
maybe she kept doing it so she still
does it right.
There's,
you still have a billboard?
Not a billboard,
but I just,
she has at least three different print
corvettes and all I've seen,
I've seen her really recently in the
pink corvette.
Yeah.
Not,
you definitely know.
You
know,
I'm more like,
I'm more of your sub do actually,
when I got the Lamborghini and I had to
go pick my sister up from the airport,
okay.
There's nowhere to put your,
put your bags.
It's a,
it's like a briefcase for,
for uh,
you know,
trunk and it's in the front.
So that was kind of silly.
Um,
and then I realized that people normally
get these cars so they can just like
kind of take it out to dinner.
I don't want to be looked at so I'm not
going to,
I'm more likely to take it to go get
groceries than I am to go to dinner.
So I realized it was pretty pointless
for me.
Yeah.
That's not the car for you.
And if I want performance,
I go do my job
for now.
For now.
But when it's over,
that's what I'm trying to look.
I'm trying to keep trying to help me.
You're,
you're looking forward.
I'm looking forward after these next two
races.
Well,
have to visit again in a year,
a year from now and,
and um,
I have to figure this,
figure it all out.
I'll tell you.
You're right.
Probably,
well in a year from now then the new
corvette zr one will be available.
750 horsepower.
Stupid 62 seconds.
I mean,
if we're going to use it,
so you might use the zero 1650 speeding
tickets.
So he talking to you negative.
True.
That's true.
Nobody get,
nobody got a speeding ticket for getting
the speed limit to quickly though.
That's true.
Yeah.
Well they probably would pull you over
anyway.
Actually,
I got a funny story about when I got
pulled over when I was 16 with my
Mustang Cobra.
I was picking my girlfriend up and
pulling out of her,
her off of her street onto the main
street and it was wet out.
And so I kind of got it going and kicked
it sideways a little bit and looked in
my rear view mirror at the stoplight.
And there's a cop sitting there.
Well he comes for me.
So I turned on the first road I can
find.
So I make a left drive down the road,
it's a fricking dead end.
So I pull into a driveway and we
slouched down real low and the COP Kinda
drives around and all of a sudden
somebody comes out from the house,
can I help you?
And I'm like,
ah,
what road is this out here?
I mean,
mind you,
it's the road I live off of.
I'm like,
Oh,
what road is this out here?
So anyway,
so we're like,
oh good.
Okay,
thank you.
Sure.
And so we,
yeah,
back in the car and the cops gone.
So we back out and head back down the
road again,
trying to get further away from the Stop
Light.
Make a left.
I look over in the parking lot across
the street,
the grade school parking lot cops
sitting there.
So I make the first right,
I can then,
so I turned right into a neighborhood
and I'm driving along and he finally
catches me and I think I cried.
Helped me.
Did he turn his lights on?
So you were running from him?
Kind of [inaudible] this guy sounds like
a shitty driver,
like a shitty cop,
but I think I got in trouble for being
sideways.
Not for speeding.
Yeah.
You should say
so I friend's car.
I don't even know how to drive this
thing.
Ben.
Actually a clever at uh,
approach.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just say I had,
I don't know what happened.
I hit the gas and then one side,
where am I getting pulled over three
times in three days episodes.
So that was number three.
I think I cried.
Maybe it was number two.
So is that why you were running from the
cops?
Like,
I just can't,
I can't keep doing this.
I just try and see if I could to just
get away.
Well,
Danica,
I think I've kept you long enough.
It was really wonderful to talk to you.
I really appreciate it.
It was really fun.
I wish you all the best of luck with
your wine and your clothes and you last
two races and,
uh,
it was a pleasure.
Thank you.
So nice to talk to teach about the whole
car situation next year and next year
you're going to want to get something
crazy.
I guarantee once you're done,
when I tell you I'm,
I'm a,
I'm missing the action.
I'll let you just call the car.
I should buy it.
Sounds like a plan.
Danica Patrick,
ladies and gentlemen,
that was fun.